this is just an editor's note i just
finished editing and had to add this
there's a fascinating discussion on
ontology and how it's related to
epistemology which occurs around the one
hour mark if you're interested in
philosophy and consciousness which you
most likely are given that you're on
this channel then make sure you at least
watch that part as ordinarily these two
divisions aren't brought together and it
was great to hear about the
interrelatedness recall that there are
timestamps in the description for all of
the videos secondly the conversation
toward the end regarding software as
akin to physical law is one that i also
haven't heard before and whether or not
i agree with it is another matter it's
at minimum thought provoking enjoy this
legendary theo locution between yoshibak
and john verveiki yoshibak is a
cognitive scientist recognized in the
field of artificial intelligence as
being one of the most unexampled and
inventive minds john verveiki is a
professor of cognitive science at the
university of toronto who's one of the
few scholars taking an extensive and
meticulous cognitive scientific approach
to the topics of wisdom buddhism and
consciousness now it's that latter topic
consciousness that in more ways than one
finds us here today click on the
timestamps in the description if you'd
like to skip this intro my name is
kirchey mungle i'm a torontonian
filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as delineating the possible
connection consciousness has to the
fundamental laws of nature
if those laws exist at all and are
knowable to us if you enjoy witnessing
and engaging with others on the topic of
psychology consciousness physics etc
then check the description for a link to
the theories of everything discord as
well as subreddit there's also a link to
the patreon that is patreon.com
if you'd like to contribute as the
patrons and the sponsors are the only
reasons that i can do podcasts with this
level of quality and depth
as now this is what i do full time
thanks to their support with regard to
sponsors there are three the first is
joining us for the first time and that's
the anagagi podcast that is a a gog
podcast it's a podcast dedicated to
philosophy psychology and consciousness
thus if you like the conversations that
we have on this channel with yoshibok
verveiki bernardo castrop and donald
hoffman etc then it's worth visiting
youtube.com slash anagogi podcast that
is a n a g o g podcast in the latest
episode of their podcast they talk about
the foundations of science and the role
irrationality has to play in science
they've also spoken to greg henriques
who has what's akin to a psychological
theory of everything called the unified
theory of knowledge anagogi podcast is
available on all podcast platforms and
it's spelt
a-n-a-g-o-g podcast the second sponsor
is brilliant during the break i decided
to brush up on some fundamentals in
physics so i committed myself to
learning one lesson per day on brilliant
some point soon i'd like to speak to
chiara marletto on constructor theory
which is predicated heavily in
information theory so i took a course on
random variable distributions and
knowledge and uncertainty despite
previously knowing the formula for
entropy as it's hammered into you as an
undergrad it was extremely edifying to
see a different explanation of the
formula for entropy that doesn't seem
like one that's been handed down
arbitrarily from god
instead after taking the course it's
easy to see why the formula for entropy
is the way that it is and how it's an
extremely natural choice there are
plenty of courses including ones on
group theory which is what's being
referenced when you hear that the
standard model has in it u1 cross su-2
cross su-3
those are technically called lead groups
visit brilliant.org
toe t-o-e to get 20 percent off your
annual subscription i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons and i
think you'll be greatly surprised at the
ease at which you can now comprehend
subjects that you previously had a
difficult time grocking at least i know
i did the third sponsor is algo algo is
an end-to-end supply chain optimization
software company with software that
helps business users optimize sales and
operations planning to avoid stockouts
reduce returns and inventory write-downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai that drives smart roi
headed by amjad hussein who himself has
a podcast on artificial intelligence and
consciousness and business growth if you
like this podcast the toe podcast and
want to support then visit omjad's
podcast link is in the description as
subscribing to amjad's channel
indirectly supports the toe channel
thank you and enjoy
i did watch uh joshua's three videos you
sent to me and there's stuff in there
that i i would i'd like to sort of pick
up on so great great
okay well i will get started on going
live
last time there was this thing you
always forgot to do and then you
remembered to do it
entangling with the valt geist
[Laughter]
um so strange
sometimes when this happens it's because
i'm not awake yet it's just a lucid
dream
so you're supposed to start flying right
you have a method to keep yourself lucid
dreaming
i used to be able to do it quite readily
in my 20s but as i've gotten older
it's not as it's not as easy for me
okay so if you can see this type in
ned's newt type ned's newt
okay we're seeing there's usually a 20
second delay between when it actually
goes live and when people see it
ned's newt
okay great
we're live
welcome so yosha
why don't we start with what you find
most interesting about john's work and
then john you'll talk about what you
find interesting about yoshos and then
we'll get into definitions
okay i find it uh fascinating that john
is a broad thinker that connects many
different angles on cognitive science
and connects this also directly with the
way in which he relates to the world so
for him science is not just the
application of methods in a certain
circumstance area but it relates to the
way in which he connects to others and
to himself and to his existence in the
world in a way and
this means that in some sense you can
count hold him accountable for his ideas
because they
directly integrate with the way in which
he thinks about
what's actually happening
i
recently had a look in his paper on
the establishment of relevance in the
cognitive system and he thinks that this
is a huge problem
and
i'm not sure if this is true but there
might be aspects where we are agreeing
or disagreeing and
perhaps this is a good starting point
later to get into the discussion
great and john
um so
um
i like that yosha is
also a big picture cognitive scientist
and um
i enjoy the fact that he
is
willing to tackle uh philosophically
challenging topics in his cognitive
science and for me i think that's much
more of that is needed in cognitive
science today
now he has a very sophisticated model of
consciousness and selfhood and there are
many points of it
that i would like to talk to him about
um
there's some things that
are interesting
he talked about
just to connect to something he said
about my work in his mind matters uh
talk he talked about the
feeling of what it's like as a primary
sense of relevance and that of course
tweaked my ears um and then he put a
quite a bit of important on attention
and as i do and trying to understand
cognition
um and so
and also within his discussions itself
um he incorporates aspects of narrative
uh and that's something i'd very much
like to talk about uh with him so
there's a lot that i find very
interesting in his work but
like i said i commend him for
um
the kind of big picture cognitive
science uh it's it's it's not as common
as it should be to my mind right now uh
so
joshua from your overview of john's work
what do you see as the disagreements you
mentioned that there are
i am not as familiar as i would need to
be to point out all the disagreements
also i don't know how much uh john's
views have changed over the last few
years and decades uh typically when you
are thinking about these questions there
is always a lot of movement in your own
mind i think and you update on ideas and
so i'm not quite sure what the current
disagreements would be but i'm sure that
there are many
just because of the multitude of things
that have to be discussed and
the angles that you can take on them
let's talk about what the definition of
consciousness is and sentience and mind
so those are consciousness sentience and
mind yosha why don't you start with your
definitions of them then we'll hear
john's because obviously we have to
disagree with the definitions yeah sure
the definitions i don't think that are
necessarily contentious points we just
need to
anchor them somehow so we agree on what
things we are talking about and what we
are not talking about i think so to me
mind is basically um the
vehicle in which everything plays out
it's basically the mechanism and
substrate that is
emergent over
mostly the activity of the brain i think
and inside of the mind there happens a
model of the world and the self and the
mind also facilitates motivation at some
level
and
then
the next term that we wanted to talk
about is sentience sentence is the
ability of a system to relate to its
environment and to discover itself in
the environment and establish this kind
of relationship and in this way learn
what it's doing
and i don't think that sentence is the
same thing as consciousness because for
instance it doesn't have to happen in
real time there doesn't need to be an
immediate reflexive awareness of this
process itself that is becoming aware
in a sense i think for instance that
corporations are usually not conscious i
think but many corporations are sentient
in the sense that they understand what
the corporation is how this corporation
relates to the world and how it
interacts with the world and plans for
it and of course the sentience of the
corporation is facilitated by the people
that work for the corporation in this
planning role but so sentience is a
functional properties that many
intelligent systems develop
and consciousness is
colloquially speaking the feeling of
what it's like it's a as a particular
phenomenology that is
it looks like something to the system
that is conscious and i think that
functionally consciousness is largely a
control model of the attention of the
system and when we say that a system is
conscious for instance a cat
or a human being what we mean is that
this system is able to act on a model of
its own awareness which means it knows
that it is aware of things and uses that
to drive its own behavior in the moment
is that distinct from self-consciousness
that it's aware that it's aware
self is slightly different because you
can be conscious without having a self
for instance in dreams you will very
often uh notice that you are conscious
but there is no eye
and also in meditative states you don't
need to focus on the eye
what typically happens though in the
type of consciousness that we have is
that we know that something is conscious
so we are aware of the awareness but
that doesn't need to have a first-person
perspective in consciousness
so i would say that first-person
perspective and consciousness even
though in our normal daytime wakeful
state are largely uh related are
actually orthogonal you can have them
independently of each other in a way
okay john so what are your definitions
or what do you agree with disagree with
well
first of all about the reference before
the sentence um
yeah i take it to my mind to refer to
um
although whether or not it forms a
unified entity it's perhaps part of the
question but what we're referring to
mine refer referring to some
unity some system
by which we are intelligent and
conscious um
and i take intelligence to be the
capacity to be a general problem solver
and
i'm not sure
um
what
the problem i have with this in
cognitive science is the term mind is
equivocal
uh people use it in different ways uh
make different identity claims a
neuroscientist perhaps saying it's brain
function
the ai person may say it's a particular
kind of learning algorithm
the psychologist will say it's you know
that which generates behavior
and the point about this is it's not
just a terminological difference
they use different methods of gathering
evidence they make different kinds of
arguments they have different kinds of
theoretical entities the psychologists
may talk about working memory
right
the
ai person may talk about certain aspects
of machine learning of course
the neuroscientists may talk about
neural net on various neural networks in
the biological sense
so i take it that what i'm trying to do
as a cognitive scientist is find out if
all of those different definitions of
mind can
uh work together
to get back to the coherent unity that
we traditionally met by the word mind so
that's part of the problem but as part
of the fun of trying to do cognitive
scientists it's often very hard
to get the anthropologist the linguist
the psychologist
um
the neuroscientist and the ai person to
all agree and you put them in the room
and then usually you throw in
philosophers who are supposed to help uh
get all that discourse from running
smoothly and they often make things more
challenging which is makes it especially
fun um so i i largely agree with what uh
yoshi said although i want to
problematize it um and specifically it's
something that cognitive sciences
asking the question what is mind is not
a clear question anymore and i think
getting clear about what that question
is is one of the tasks of cognitive
science
so um
sentience um
an awareness and uh
i i tend to have i tend to buy
instentions to maidson's notion of
sentience
uh
[Music]
which is a way i think it might overlap
with what yoshi means by awareness but a
sentient system is one that can in some
sense size up
its situation
um it it's aware of it but not in just
sort of the nebulous sense
uh right it it it can foreground in
background information uh things like
that um so perhaps i think a little bit
of a tighter connection between
sentience and uh perceptual awareness
consciousness uh consciousness um
is usually sort of two aspects and of
course there's a all of this everything
i'm saying here is fraught and you
should know this right
people talk about two aspects of
consciousness
there's one
aspect that's often called access
consciousness this is part of what
consciousness means is my my i can ready
things i can make things ready for a
reason i can make them ready for problem
solving
and i can bring aspects of my you know
of my skills and my perception and my
understanding together
um
and then there's what's called the
phenomenal and some people say
phenomenological there's a bit of
confusion around that but anyways as you
said this is the feeling of what it's
like what it's like to be me here now in
this situation
it could mean that it can mean something
very primitive like what is it like to
experience green and this is the
so-called problem of qualia
and so one way people think of
consciousness is the the place where
qualia exists
um
for me there's two central questions we
we are asking and part of what i would
argue is we need to integrate them
together and one of the the strengths i
see of yoshi's work is i do see him
attempting and i don't mean attempting
as a as a as an insult we're all
attempting here um
attempting to integrate these two
questions together one is the function
question which is basically what the
hell does consciousness do
given that so much
so much of our intelligent behavior
happens unconsciously what is
consciousness for some people are
willing to say it's not for anything
it's just an epiphenomenon doesn't do
anything it has no function yoshi
doesn't say that i'm not saying he does
the other question is the nature problem
how is it that something like
consciousness exists in this physical
world which
amongst all these objects don't seem to
have any of these subjective uh
properties qualia things like that at
least since the scientific revolution we
separated all of those out from uh the
physical universe and we put them in
this place
now i happen to think that you should
try and answer those questions together
in an integrated fashion
one of the criticisms i have of some of
the central theories is they tend to
answer one question
while neglecting the other and vice
versa
um
so i think that's
my
best i had to say a little bit more
because he went first so i had to sort
of take into what uh yoshi said uh but
that's um
trying to answer
any good definition of consciousness
should try and answer the function and
the nature questions in an integrated
fashion
john you said that some people say that
consciousness is where qualia exist what
do you mean
so one way i mean this goes back largely
to descartes and it's picked up by locke
so
galileo made a distinction between
primary qualities
and right or qualia
and secondary uh primary qualities are
ones that are mathematically measurable
in some on some sense like you know the
length of an object its mass things like
that and galileo proposed that those
were real they were in the objective
world
and then there are all the qualia that
are not mathematic mathematically
measurable
like the the experience
not the reflectance pattern but the
experience of greenness the experience
of sweetness the experience of beauty
perhaps and so for for descartes
following up on galileo those things did
not exist in the world they existed only
in the mind they were therefore only in
the subject they were subjective
and that's qualia now the idea is
there's lots of your there's lots of
stuff happening in the mind
unconsciously that doesn't seem to be
generating any of that qualitative
experience it only seems to be the case
or it seems to be the case that not only
seems to be it seems to be the case that
those qualia only exist when i'm awake
alert and aware in some fashion um and
so they seem to be in consciousness now
that that in is at best metaphorical but
that's how many people many people take
that to be
the central phenomena
of consciousness
and that the problem of consciousness is
largely the problem of answering that
uh other people think other
other aspects of consciousness aren't
central like intentionality the
consciousness seems to be about things
directed at things
josh did you have any comments on any of
what john said so uh personally i don't
think that the aboutness is so much the
problem but um we can go into what we
personally find puzzling about the
entire affair
and
with respect to qualia i think that
there are two aspects that should be
kept separate one is
what is the difference between
these elements and features of
experience and the measurement
and the other one is what makes them
experiential what is experience itself
and
the first question is something that
became i think quite apparent in
early work that i participated in
robotics we taught little sony ibro
robots to play soccer and in the course
of this task they had to watch balls
moving over a field and we had to
segment out the balls and when the task
was set up by the people who developed
this game
uh we already
made this task as easy as possible at
least we thought we made the field
extremely and homogeneously green there
were some white lines on the field but
still and the ball was very orange
and unfortunately the ball was a little
bit reflecting and the field was also
taking up some of these reflections and
we thought we could solve the problem
basically with the lookup table where we
just would match certain color values
from the rgb sensors of the camera of
the robot to whether it's wall or field
and this didn't work
we found that the pixels below the ball
were more orange than the pixels at the
bottom of the ball were not green
so in some sense if we just did collar
tables the the colors were at the in the
area where the ball touched the field
were inverted
and so we needed to be more intelligent
we needed to figure out ultimately of
whether pixels that we see in a certain
region of the
field
are probably part of the ball and are
probably part of the field and depending
on this context we would have to
reinterpret them
and so i noticed that
a color is not just a certain wavelength
or a certain rgb value that you take
from your camera sensor it's an
interpretation that is qualitatively
bound to the context in which it's being
measured
so
the property of redness is not just a
certain uh rtb value it is
given in the context of a red object um
the interpretation of the surface
properties in the stationary way of that
object right so it's a property that
attaches to to an object in a certain
context redness is the property that is
shared by all the right objects and you
cannot separate redness from this in the
processing
if you have changing lighting and real
world lighting
so there needs to be some kind of
feature processing that makes
that turns a measurement into a
context-dependent feature
that is in
multiple dimensions qualitative
so i think it's a happy accident that
this rhymes to qualia it's not actually
the reason but this answers i think to
some degree the first question
why is um
are the elements of experience different
for measurements and what distinguishes
them for measurements but it doesn't
answer the second question what is it to
experience
why is this thing part of my inner
reality
and this is to be explained in a
different way it has to be explained by
a certain kind of architecture and this
is what some people find very passing it
doesn't look that puzzling to me and we
can look into the details of what it
looks like but for instance one
important aspect is
that we can learn to deconstruct the
qualitative experience of the things
that we're looking at so when we look
for instance at a face what we typically
see is
an expression in the face
it's not just a geometrical arrangement
of features but we can't stare for a
face for long enough until the faceness
of the face disappears and the only
thing that's left is the geometrical
arrangement and we can go further and
let the geometry disappear and we just
see colored blubs and flickering and so
on and
in this way we can start deconstructing
the elements of our experience and once
we see how they are deconstructed we can
also get a glimpse in how they are
constructed in the first place
one of my students once told me you know
there's a via very weird thing i can see
faces in power plugs
and uh there's a vault software
involved sockets right if you look at a
power socket in a wall you can uh people
can see your face in here it said yeah
most people can do that right it's uh
called a parado layer it's basically
this ability to see uh
faces and other things in patterns in
our environment
and so on and see that but you know
there are no faces in power sockets
and i told her yeah the dark secret is
there are also no faces on people
you just project them there right it's
there intrinsically there's just
geometry
it's this thing that there is something
that you look at
another one that looks at you that looks
out of their eyes and is interpreting
the world in a particular vein you see
that in their face you see in their face
what they feel and so on how they relate
to you this is just a projection that
your mind is making it's not actually a
visual feature it's a high level
interpretation of things like the
emotional state and so on that are all
mixed into your interpretation of
reality
um so
i guess uh what i i don't have any
disagreement with that uh
at least right now
um i i i'm in agreement with this idea
that when we're talking about
perception and
we're talking about doing things in
terms of a context dependence and then
the sensitivity to that the sensitivity
to context and conduct
context dependence i think is really
really crucial
i see that sensitivity as bound up with
uh the capacity for interpretation
interpretation means uh being able to
in some way direct your attention or
awareness to some features rather than
others because you can of course take in
all possible features of of the object
or the environment etc
so i guess i see those two processes as
a little bit more closely related and
i do think that part of what it's like
to experience a face
is to find it relevant in a particular
fashion to find it as fitted to that
context and fitted to your task within
that context
and i think that
also as joshua said i think that goes
into the perception of it so i see i
guess perhaps a deeper interpenetration
between
the perception and the interpretation um
that goes around uh ideas like i've been
talking about about relevance
realization
um
now
there's there was an interesting um move
made there and i don't know how fast we
want to go onto logical um where there
was um
you know the face isn't really there
and um
it's just a projection um
and so um i'm not quite sure what that
means
maybe yoshi can
because i take it for example
that
that would generalize to everything in
my experience
that i find meaningful
and
like um do i want to say
that the various you know gauges i'm
using in science are just projections um
do i want to say that the other people
that are debating with me are just
projections so i get
to do
yeah
uh but the problem is is is
um there's an implicit normativity of
realness there
that
um i guess i i want i uh i want to
unpack a little bit
because like i said i think the point
that yoshi made just generalizes to
everything
and then i i i have sort of
epistemological and ontological concerns
about that
because it might i'm not saying it does
i'm saying it might sort of lead me into
kind of a solar cystic skepticism which
makes the very pro the very attempt to
do science itself kind of implausible um
so
what is it i mean surely there might
surely maybe not surely
there must be
uh perception that counts as observation
of the environment i take it um and
why is it not just a projection i guess
is my question
yes so
this particular point relates to the
question of whether faces are part of
res extensor
and
we have to
sort out what we mean by res extension
the typical way in which descartes is
interpreted is that there are two
substances out in physics in a way
ontologically at the level at which the
universe exists and one of these
substances is stuff in space the
extended things the objects in the world
and then we have res cognitives which is
the space of ideas in which the mind
exists and somehow they interact with
each other so basically the mind exists
in a different dimension of the universe
and remote controls the physical body uh
via the pineal gland or um
as popper and eccles suggested via the
neocortex which is some kind of magical
quantum antenna which talks to the mind
in a different realm that is not in
physics and i think this is an um
misunderstanding that
ultimately can be mapped to faulty on
epistemology so there is a
weird perspective on what we think is
and in the way in which it is
constituted it's also reflected in the
christian
interpretation of the genesis
and maybe this is not unrelated because
it's part of the same cultural tradition
this interpretation of genesis and the
interpretation of descartes
and
in genesis we have the creation of a
physical universe by a supernatural
being in the common interpretation
and it starts out with the creation of
light and darkness which are separated
from each other and then the creation of
sky and ground and then the plants and
the animals eventually and then they all
get their name
but we do know that
sky and ground are not physical entities
and colors are not in physics there are
constructions that only happen in our
mind and and when we look at
foundational physics we see a weird
quantum graph that has
a very complicated properties among them
apparently the property to throws
regular patterns at our systemic
interface so our brain can find
regularity in them and part of these
regularities that our mind is
discovering in quite reliable ways is
darkness and brightness and sky and
ground and plants and animals and giving
them all their names which is cognitive
development so the universe that you and
me are interacting with
experientially
and also intersubjectively is not a
physical universe you're not talking
about entities in physics and we talk
about the universe to each other we
largely talk about entities in our
experience
and now it turns out that this
experience that our brain is
constructing for us to relate to which
is a core screening of the patterns that
the physical universe throws at us
contain
two types of entities
and one group of entities is what we
could call stuff in space it's like a
physics engine in a computer game so we
have
a three-dimensional basically euclidean
space in which we have extended objects
that occupy volumes and these objects
can be solid or liquid or gaseous and
they displace each other and they have
all these properties that we would call
rest extensor but this res extensor is
geometric it's mechanical
it doesn't want something it's just
moving in a mechanical way
and so when the student said that there
are no faces
uh in power sockets what she meant is
that the physical thing the res extends
i think the geometrical thing the face
is not really on the power plug and i
pointed to her out that the face itself
is not a geometrical thing so when you
see a face what you see is not actually
a geometry it's not part of something
that you would construct with a 3d
program
what you have to construct is a certain
part of res cognitives it's a certain
interpretation of a high-level feature
that is already a mental feature that we
see this intentional entity in the world
expressed by uh its interface to the
world and so i i think this way we can
uh john and me probably agree on a way
in which we disassemble the category or
at least make the next step
and so i would agree that of course
every entity that we make out in the
universe ultimately is an imposition
that our mind is making this imposition
is not necessarily an arbitrary one
because the universe cannot be
officially encoded in every possible way
there are certain ways in which the
encoding makes sense and others where it
doesn't help you to interpret the world
so the way in which we um
draw the boundaries between objects is
not arbitrary but the boundaries are
drawn by our mind
okay so um
of course you're aware of the i mean
first of all a comment um i do think
there's a deep connection between
um the christian models which is sort of
a two worlds mythology
and descartes uh dualism of mind and
body so i think that's an accurate
historical observation um
i talk a bit about that connection in my
awakening from the meeting crisis series
so um
in fact i often talk about christian
cartesianism as the as the link between
those so i think that's a good a good
historical observation
of course the the deep problem uh with
finding that division of res extension
and res cognitives
to be the sort of final note on your
ontology is the problem that beset
descartes which is the problem that
spinoza immediately
recognized is that there's no possible
causal interaction between these domains
and you get the separation of right
reasons from causes and you get all of
these kind kinds of problems um
and so i take it that there is something
fundamentally wrong with the ontology if
it's giving us that kind of
deep i mean it strikes me as absurd to
say that my mental states whatever they
happen to be in my physical states are
not causally interacting with each other
uh on an ongoing basis
and you know that
i if i if
if i presume that kind of dualism then
of course i can also pick up on your
mental states because all i get is your
bodily behavior etc and if there is no
causal relationship between your mental
states and your bodily behavior um then
of course i can't
pick up on other minds
and so
i mean
you i know you know this because you've
mentioned it in one of the one of the
talks i mean that ontology is always
deeply problematic because it generates
these really really um
powerful and perfect uh yeah dualism is
very difficult to get to work
and
i
think that the solution is relatively
simple uh res extensor and res
cognitions both exist in the mind they
are just different domains in which we
make sense of the world one is this
mechanical level of geometric perception
and the other one is hidden states
of intentional systems that animate part
of this world
and
the
when a meditator believes that uh
res cognitants uh is uh separate from uh
res extensor and uh res extends us out
there in the physical world and
experiencing the physical world and they
managed to
go to this state of reality construction
where this boundary between self and
world is obliterated and they suddenly
notice this unity of the system and oh
my god everything is consciousness uh
they became pancakists but right it's
that's a fundamental confusion that
results uh from uh this error in the
ontology
and
uh when i was young i stumbled on the
same uh issue as you just mentioned uh
if you are a dualist
how does this interface between
the causally closed physical universe
and
the mind work
there are some solutions to this like
for instance
occasionalism which means they just
happen to be synchronous but there is no
direct connection between them and
ultimately this is a form of epi
phenomenalism so it would not be a
violation of the causal closure of
physics if your
ontologically separate mind would be
reading it but wouldn't have right
access right so you could have this
physical universe mechanically clicking
uh
by itself but you could have the mind
looking at it from the outside but as
soon as the mind writes you should be
able sometimes to see certain violations
of the conservation of energy or the
conservation of information in the lab
and apparently you don't and popper and
eccles hope that it's possible to
basically uh hide this in the randomness
of quantum events but still it would
need to be a systematic violation so i
don't think that this would work
and the attempts to
solve this problem i think that
they they don't work out
so i thought there is two possibilities
one is either we are in an entirely
mechanical universe and there is no
conspiracy going on of course it's also
possible that the mechanical universe is
in some kind of simulation right so we
could be running in some kind of nerd's
computer
that is stationed in the next
level universe and of course this nerd
could also interact with our world and
in a sense dualism in some sense might
be possible it could also be that our
minds indeed run on a separate machine
and interact with it but in this sense
every supernatural thing would have to
have a natural cause at some level in
one of the parent universes just
unfortunately this uh
intermediate level could be a symbolic
one
and the symbolic universe is a magical
universe
right if you have a magical interaction
that for instance in minecraft you can
open up a shell and you can say times
that day and the sun rises and there is
no process within the cellular automaton
of minecraft that explains this
mechanical you would have to go a level
uh behind that and understand the way in
which the minecraft universe is
constituted as some kind of simulation
and simulacrum and part running on a
computer and a parent universe that
allows you to do magic
but uh
a step back the alternative to the
mechanical universe
of physics and physicalism is the idea
that there is a mechanical universe
happening in base reality and we are
directly emergent over that base
universe so we don't live in some kind
of simulation that that is physicalism
and
the alternative is we live in a dream
and in the dream magic is possible in a
dream it's possible that you can break
the laws of physics it's possible that
you can have telepathy in a way that
violates the standard model and you can
have ghosts and you can have all sorts
of weird things for which you cannot
possibly have a physical explanation
maybe for some of them there are
physical explanations but by and large
this is the main
boundary and when you look at the
philosophies that exist
there are basically these two types of
big philosophical approaches that exist
in the history of humanity that are
either fully monistically idealist and
say we do live in a dream and the
idealists have to explain why this dream
looks in many parts so damn regular
and uh mechanical
oh and the other group says the universe
is entirely mechanical and this group
has to explain why so many magic things
seem to be happening
and then we have to find an agreement
which of the things are mechanical and
which of the things are magical and why
right and
at some point it became apparent to me
that we obviously do live in a dream
but that this dream
would have to be dreamt
by some kind of
mind in a higher plane of existence
probably in some kind of mechanical
fashion because you need functionality
that facilitates the interaction of the
elements on your dream because it's not
random this is also apparent when you
have a lucid dream right if once you
observe a number of your lucid dreams
you notice how they are composed you
notice some of the mechanisms of of
lucid dreaming you notice some of the
limitations of how many elements can be
stable for how long and you lose the
dream and so on the ways in which you
interact with them and so the lucid
dream itself becomes apparent as
something that is facilitated by
mechanisms
and so what would be the properties of
that higher plane of existence and i
think this higher plane of existence is
physics
right physical systems cannot be
conscious only simulated things can be
conscious consciousness is a virtual
property it's simulated it exists in the
dream and the system that dreams us
according to our best theories right now
is the brain in physics
and the confusion that we have about
this when we think about this arises
through the notion that what we
experience when we look at brains our
brains but we don't these squishy pink
things are elements of our dream that
are generated in non-random fashion in
the parent reality and the parent
reality is something that we can never
have access to we cannot experience
physics there is no way in which the
physical world can be experienced from
inside of a brain
so
wouldn't that mean then that there's no
knowledge of the physics possible then
no this does what it means
we can have knowledge from first
principles which means we can
understand the way in which thinking
could possibly happen which means
understanding the realm of all languages
in the way in which something could mean
something that's one aspect so we have a
priori knowledge which is
a category of ideas that we get by
understanding how systems can
be about other things you can understand
how languages work
and the other thing is that we can
make observations and we can identify
regularities and the observations and
then using our understanding of first
principles to get a notion of what the
significance of these observables is
and so i think it's a good
simplification to say that we find
regular patterns at our systemic
interface and in these regular patterns
we find
um non-random ways to disassemble them
and build them into hierarchies of
features and objects
um
i don't know if
i don't know i made myself clear what i
was trying to get at
are you
maybe i i should ask a question first
are you proposing that you can do
physics at priori
because that doesn't seem to be the case
um
we tried to do physics out prior that
state cards project and it collapses you
can't do physics out prior are you
seeing as you said and then you said we
can
observe regularities which i think is
what physics does but that means you're
saying that regularities are really
there
and then i guess the problem becomes
uh
what privileges those experiences of i
mean i can have to use your analogy i
can have regularities in my dream and i
don't take them to have given me um an
account of how the world really is
um
but if i do say that regularities work
um what is it about them that gets me
outside of
the simulation i'm worried about i'm
worried about a problem of skepticism
here i'm worried about a problem of
right am i this is what you know this is
what hume does he says well you know
you've got all these regularities but
those regularities are themselves only
projected by the mind the causation is
just association between
ideas and experiences and therefore i
really can't know the world
and kant etc and so i i guess
i'm wondering if there seems to be a i
mean
to say things are a projection is to say
that other things are real because it's
a contrast term to say that everything
is an illusion for example doesn't make
any sense it's like saying everything's
tall right um so i'm i'm trying to get
out what is like what surely we must
have experiences that count as access to
the real or else we are just locked
inside an attorney an internal
self-referential system that's what i'm
that's what i'm asking
did that make sense um yes but let's
start out with um one of these aspects
there are several
points that we i think would need to
address and some of them are veritable
rabbit holes so let's start out with the
problem of skepticism
personally i don't see skepticism as a
problem because i think that
when i am
observing
the trajectories that my mind can take
there is not usually many points where i
open a door and go through and i cannot
go back
right it's not that i uh in the course
of intellectual exploration uh go
through one-way dwarfs
that i can see before and i say um
i cannot come back this might exist in
some religions so uh here is a wonderful
delicious brain worm
you take it on and you can give it back
in three weeks from now and ideologies
uh usually work in such a way that they
warp your mind in such a way that you
get cut off from the rest of human
thought space and you cannot come back
and i i think that in the rational world
this cannot happen so when you think
rationally
everything that you think is conditional
on something else
and so
everything that is not impossible is
possible
and the confidence among the possible
things has to be disputed distributed
according to the evidence that is
available
so uh the possibility that
nothing exists in the way in which i
perceive it and i don't exist and other
people don't exist or only i exist and
all the other people exist is always a
possibility and there is nothing scary
about it and they don't need to be
worried about it there are no
assumptions that they need to make to
avoid this so i never fall into this
trap and never come back oh my god no
it's not not a problem the possibility
that there are no other people
should be considered
and i should see uh what observations
suggest that this is the case and which
observations speak against it and uh if
i ever find out that there never been
other people why should i be surprised
right it's i should consider this i
should see how deep the rabbit hole goes
there's nothing scary about it's not
infinitely deep they're not infinitely
many conclusions that i will draw from
this this will not lock me in an
inhospitable place of the intellectual
universe if i consider this path
so i would suggest basically consider
the entire space of possibilities and uh
the idea that there are other minds in
the world that are constituted in a
quite similar way to mine but have a
larger diversity it's then some people
might be willing to acknowledge at first
glance and so on right this seems to be
a good theory there seem to be other
objects that look a lot like me in this
mind and they seem to be like me the
side effect of the regulation needs of
the hairless monkey
in the present universe and uh
this so it's a good theory it gives good
predictions it's a useful encoding of
the patterns that are thrown at my
systemic boundary
and uh this there's another aspect to uh
solipsism which is more an experiential
one this is if you cannot perceive other
minds as minds based on the prayers that
you have
most people don't learn a lot of wisdom
in their life and that their wisdom they
have is largely a structure that is
innate to them they are lucky to be born
wise
and they just converge in the
observation of the world to more details
in in this structure and so only people
that are born unwise have difficulty to
ever get to wisdom so we do learn new
structure but largely the architecture
that we use to interpret the world seems
to be
something that is
to a large degree innate that is mapped
to the circumstances that our ancestors
found themselves in in the world and
what we noticed for instance many
europeans that live in the u.s have all
these weird quirks in which they relate
to the world that are the remnant of
non-existent european societies that
they're brought
within their own minds and the structure
that is built into their soul over many
generations and now
they try this in this very brutish and
weird pioneer society that is the us
and many of these patterns don't make
sense and this is not just the case for
europeans it's just for europeans i can
notice and interpret these patterns
better than for other cultures that are
part of this hodgepodge of the us
and so it's very interesting to see that
uh solipsism might be a property of some
people i i sometimes think that our
previous president has been a solipsist
not in the sense that he's an evil
person i think it's psychologically
interesting that uh when he talks to
other people his important criterion was
always
he can't say whatever he wants as long
as he gets away with it and
communication is a tool to get what he
wants
and it seems to be somewhat invariant in
politics but he beelines for it right he
is able to think outside of a box
because he never acknowledged the
existence of this box
there is a certain prior that there are
other minds that he need to share truth
with
that is absent he can just say whatever
he wants he's free to do this because
there are no other people
there's only something like an almost
faceless audience that relates to him in
a particular way and that he relates to
in a particular way that makes them fit
for this particular role it was probably
unwise to to make this
tangent because they don't want to make
a normative statement one way or the
other about trump they just think that
he happens to be somebody that we all
know and who's psychologically
interesting because i think he might be
as all-obsessed in an experiential
functional not necessarily a
philosophical sense
so don't worry josh i'm not going to
draw you into any kind of political
debate around uh trump
um so that uh that would be uh unfair to
you and unfair to the spirit in which
you offered the example um
now i i'm trying to think of what how to
reply because you said about 7000 really
interesting things in that last thing uh
but one thing i i i seem to pick up on
was that
you know
reality seems to be determined by
rational processes of making sense
um which
i mean and that's a classical kind of
idealism that's sort of like a yelling
idealism that ultimately the real is
dependent on
on the on the capacity for rationality
and so rationally has to be as real as
anything else because of that dependency
relationship
now the thing about that is rationality
seems to be
a quintessential mental property too um
and
does that mean
that we don't have
i mean
you know you know you know this too i
know you know again i've seen your talks
you know the problems of deep time that
idealism faces right the problem with
deep time uh you know um there seems to
be a significant difference between
darwin discovering the theory of
evolution in 1859 process of rational
reflection gathering the evidence and
the process of evolution that actually
led to darwin's existence right they
have different they have different
temporal
spatial extensions etc and so
the the problem
i guess i'm trying to get at is
when i'm talking about it that way
doesn't that mean that i have to
uh take it that that rationality really
exists
since my ability to
determine what is real is dependent on
my rational processes like you said
better theories worth series making
better sense uh etc etc and then that
seems to indicate a very high level of
organization at which things can be real
rather than just
what is typically taken to be
the physical i take it that at least
traditionally at least currently
rationality is not part of the ontology
of physics it's presupposed in the
practice of physics but it's not part of
the ontology um
and so that that means it sounds to me
either like you have a kind of strong
idealism or because you brought this up
as another possibility
you see rationality as emerging perhaps
out of intelligence and intelligence
emerging out of the behavior of the
brain
but it wouldn't be an epiphany it could
not be given this argument at the
phenomenal emergence rationality would
have to be a real thing
that really exists and really
directs people's behavior in some
fashion
how does that land with you or have i
misinterpreted you
so we probably have to agree on what we
mean by rationality
to be able to disassemble this term a
little bit further
typically it's the ability to uh reach a
certain goal in which you have reason to
believe that uh these tools that you use
are suitable to get to that goal
it it's i i would add in in addition to
the instrumentality aspect of
rationality that rationality includes a
capacity for self-correction
uh so the system has to be able to
correct itself as it's pursuing these
goals and be able to seek out more
reliable
means of achieving achieving those goals
so the sit and so the system is
inherently self-correcting
which means in a very important way the
system has to be self-transcending in
some fashion it has to be able to exceed
itself and has to be able to grow it has
to be able to develop so there's there's
something but i see this all part of the
uh
i don't think that
if you are in a suitably complex
environment with complex tasks that you
can be
believed that your strategy is the only
suitable one and doesn't need some kind
of mechanism of self-correction so
self-correction i think falls relatively
early out of the instrumental notion
yeah i don't have any problem with that
yeah i just want to i just wanted to
point out that that's often not
explicated in accounts of
instrumentality so
yeah go ahead but uh i don't think that
rationality in this sense is necessarily
a thing that exists as an object but
it exists as an archetype
it exists as a strategy that i can
specify from some basic desirables for
any kind of system that is strategizing
on solving a control problem in in a
complex world
so
basically if you have a system that is
has the ability to error correct on a
deep level and that is able to discover
enough regularities in the world to
notice its own existence in the world
then
the system as soon as it's able to
evaluate the strategies that it applies
to make sense of the world will discover
rationality as an option
and
there are not that many alternatives to
it and when you think about how to be an
a rational idealist
right if you are a deep idealist can you
afford to be rational there is in some
sense two possibilities in which you are
an idealist one is an idealist that is
willing to deal with the french problem
of idealism like why is there regularity
in there and where does the dream come
from
and the alternative is mysterianism
and mysterianism is a position in
cognitive science that is held by
several people mysterianism basically
says that something cannot be understood
if it cannot be understood by norm
chomsky
and uh
not surprisingly uh chomsky himself is a
mysterionist about consciousness
uh
yeah and i think uh
yeah i i think begin with the similar
things yeah uh
for me before we uh i don't want to get
too far feel about this i think there's
equivocation around uh
miserianism
uh it invokes uh uh i think a
non-controversial notion of epistemic
boundedness like every other organism
it's highly probable we are
epistemically bounded
um and then it claims we're
epistemically bounded with respect uh to
um
to the mind like
having a mind doesn't mean that the mind
is capable of explaining itself uh and
that of course is i i don't think chimps
will ever generate a theory explaining
their own cognition etc i think that's
non-controversial the problem um is the
specific argument
saying that that is actually occurring
in our attempts to solve consciousness
or intelligence etc so i think i
well i agree about
the egocentrism of some of the arguments
that you've pointed to i think there's
also a deep equivocation there between
uh different senses of epistemic
boundedness that hasn't been
sort of properly worked out very
carefully of course i think like i said
in one sense it's got to be
non-controversial i think that we're
epistemically bounded even younger
versions of myself were epistemically
bounded with respect to these uh
problems and questions the idea is how
do i know how do i distinguish between
epistemic boundedness that is sort of
hardwired into me
cultural epistemic boundedness
historical epistemic boundedness
developmental epistemic boundedness and
so i i find that that whole argument um
sort of deeply confused because there's
a lot of equivocation going on so i take
it that you don't like it either so um
well i think it's it's maybe an
unhelpful notion because uh in the way
in which the term is constructed it
suggests that there is indeed a hard
bound
and the question is is is this a useful
way to think about the way in which my
experience works so maybe uh chimpanzees
are just stupid people and uh because
they have a very short childhood so they
uh before their brain loses
neuroplasticity and at all the
respective levels where they would be
able to form concepts it already
solidifies and they're not able to make
sense of the world at dessert beyond a
certain depth because it's for them
difficult to focus for on these ideas
for long enough and uh to build um
suitable representations about them and
a similar thing happens with people most
people are unable to focus on an idea
for more than 20 minutes if it's not
related to their social or erotic
success
and
so
you need very weird people that are able
to focus on certain ideas for very very
long and then we already die after a few
decades
does this imply that there is a higher
epidemic bound probably not
and there could be a harder epistemic
bound that is we can figure out um
by the timing characteristics how many
layers our brain effectively has our
brain is not organized in need layers
it's recurrent and so on but still
it seems to be difficult for us to hold
thoughts beyond a certain length or
construct thoughts beyond a certain
length it's for most people very
difficult to hold a thought in their
mind stable that is longer than a few
tens of seconds and some people are able
to hold the thoughts stable in their
mind that takes a few hours but this
means uninterrupted focus on this
thought
and so if you think about how many
oscillations can you fit into such a
thought
is the level of complexity that this
model has sufficient to understand
foundational physics for instance and it
could be that uh foundational physics
poses a few questions that are close to
the boundary of what we can integrate
all at once and that we need machines to
extend our mind to keep the thought
stable and detailed for long enough
i think it is unfair to expect from
descartes that he is able to solve
foundational physics because there were
many fundamental insights that were not
available to him that were not part of
uh what he had time to figure out by
himself and uh that were not available
to him in books and ideas around him he
largely still lived in a euclidean
universe in which the objects were very
large
and in which it was not apparent how to
build more simple automata over which
the complexity of
the three-dimensional approximately
three-dimensional euclidean world or
space-time later on would emerge
so
in this time there was no way to go to
uh to understand the emergence of
physics from something that is more
simple and closer to first principles
and i think this is only just now
happening that i i think
that's what i was trying to say
and issues of epistemic boundedness are
mixing up and confusing together
biological issues cultural issues
historical issues yes right so maybe
epistemic boundaries is not a thing so
that was my point uh so it might exist
approximately but uh if you treat it as
the oh my god there's this boundary
there it is there is the wall that
separates us uh from um
from the next country and we will never
be able to cross it because this is uh
for some a natural law the reason in
which human minds have to be constructed
i am not sure if you can actually make
that claim if you can prove that there
is a boundary that we need to run
against well this is hegel's argument
and maybe i can use that to circle back
because hegel's argument is you can
actually only uh
talk about a limit if you have the
capacity to exceed it uh it doesn't make
any sense to say from just this side
that there's a limit
so there are boundaries uh one is uh
there is loops theorem which says that a
system basically cannot make statements
uh about something outside of itself
also the way in which griddle for
instance talks about the whole of
mathematics and these properties of
mathematics works by building an
automaton that reconstructs the whole of
mathematics that he wants to talk about
from first principles so it talks about
something that is contained in the
system if i want to talk about the whole
of mathematics
i have to talk about it by
reconstructing it from first principles
if i cannot make such a definition i
don't know what i'm talking about right
so the world that i am talking about is
one that i need to construct in the
first place and i'm not able to talk
about something that exists outside of
these constructions unless i can prove
that i have constructed things in the
only possible way
which means i have to make statements
about the possible nature of language
itself so this is one of the boundaries
that i can run into
and
the other one is has to do with uh
the problem of the access to
of the universe itself and this is much
more
obvious to people then live theory even
though it's related uh you cannot
exclude the possibility that for
instance that you could be a brain in
the vet some philosophers have tried to
do this but there are slate of hands and
wishful thinking
there is no way that you and me cannot
uh know beforehand of whether we are
currently in
some kind of weird dream from which we
wake up in the next moment and realize
oh my god this actually didn't happen it
was a fake memory this uh was not true
this is not a description of the
physical universe this was just a weird
illusion that i had in a night dream but
there is no way in which we can in
principle exclude this possibility there
is only ways in which we can
deal with the probabilities based on our
past experiences but if we have never
experienced a certain thing before in
this fundamental way for instance after
i had a long surgery for eight hours i
had extremely lucid dreams that had that
were so intense that i could not in the
intensity distinguish them from daytime
experiences
and it was because of the narcotics that
were still in my bloodstream and i never
had experiences like that before
of course these experiences were just
brain states they had nothing prophetic
about this this was not an alternate
universe that i was dropping in but the
experiential qualities were very similar
and i so my argument is that you can not
possibly make such a distinction
beforehand and that's why you can also
not exclude the possibility of
skepticism and this is one of the
boundaries of what we can be achieving
as a mind we cannot rely on our own
coherence
in a fundamental sense we always have to
hope and pray that the world
remains as coherent as it appears to me
right now in the next thought
so that that gets i that um
that gets me back to the point
that realness seems to be bound uh to
some normative notion of rationality
you've invoked a priori a couple times
uh the problem with that priori is again
that hasn't been stable what khan
thought was that priori and he famously
um positive the opera ri right as
central um you know many people don't
agree with his set uh uh our priority
that you know that logic that that logic
is aristotelian logic there's many
logicians that say no that's not the
only possible logic
[Music]
euclidean geometry is the only geometry
that's not true etc um and so again it
seems that even the app priori is
dependent on these more basic processes
of how we
think everything's hangs together how
everything is intelligible how it all
makes sense to us
and for me that um
that's the thing i really want to
understand
i really want to understand
how and why
um we find the universe intelligible
and if we're justified in doing so and
then how does that relate to
intelligence and consciousness
that's the sort of that's the issue
and i take it that there are sort of
certain central problems
that go back to
um this fundamental act of
interpretation which is what are you
going to pay attention to how long
you're going to pay attention to it how
much importance are you going to give to
it how you're going to prioritize one
thing over another
etc
and
interestingly enough these are kind of a
lot of the contending candidates for
theories about what it attention is
and i know you put a lot of
centrality on attention in your meant in
your
model of consciousness
and so i'm very interested and i talk
about this process
by which we attend to things
in the right way
so that we're capable of making
um intelligible sense of our experience
in a way that gives us some
good reason i'm not saying
demonstratively certain but some good
reason it could be probabilistic if you
want uh for saying x is real and y is
not
um because
if we can't do that if we can't make
those basic kinds of distinctions we
can't do science itself and then a lot
of the data that we're using to make our
arguments falls through the bottom
because we have no ontological ground
for science itself
so
i'm very interested in exactly those
kinds of fundamental issues um
of
how
so for me
the problem of consciousness ultimately
is bound up with the problem of
intelligence the problem of making sense
but those are not just psychological
problems they are ultimately
epistemological ontological problems and
answering them together i think is
something well that's what i'm trying to
do with you here now i'm trying to get
um
how it is
that i'm trying to get your model of
ontology um and
where because you you do you have to
rely on judgment so like you went back
uh it's only a projection there's not
really a face there
that's a that's a positing of what's
real versus not real
and i'm trying to get at
is your account
of
rationality bound up with your account
of consciousness and intelligence it
seems like it is um and doesn't that
mean therefore that we have to posit a
certain kind of realness
to intelligence and consciousness the
way we have to for rationality because
rationality is how we determine what's
real in the world again i acknowledge
with you i'm not saying that i can do
that
you know with any kind of certainty but
nevertheless i have to be able to do it
in some kind of fashion i have to be
able to make judgments about real versus
not real in order to be generating the
kind of data
we're both using when we're talking here
right now
so here's the argument in a nutshell
it seems that what's real depends on
what's rational and being rational seems
to
require some kind of self-awareness
not
some kind of consciousness and rational
seems to also uh require some kind of
basic ability to be intelligent
to
find certain things relevant rather than
others to pay attention to here uh to
see the relevance of certain acts to
goals et cetera
and doesn't that mean therefore that
consciousness and
intelligence and rationality are just as
real
as anything else that we posit to be
real
the question is what is real and it's a
it's a tricky question it's one question
yes uh
the property of ex being experientially
real requires i think that it needs to
be in our mind
so
there is no way in which you can wake up
from the dream in your mind and still
exist because
out there in physics you are not
conscious neurons are not conscious
brains are not conscious physical
apparatuses are not conscious you need
to be inside of that dream so if you
ever transcend the dream
you will not be there the experience of
waking up is something that you dream
you can only
experience waking up while you are still
in a dream
and so
you're not going to wake up in some any
kind of reality
and
there is this big question why there is
something rather than nothing it seems
to be hard to deny that something exists
and it's difficult to figure out how
it's possible that there is something
rather than nothing
and the easiest explanation that uh
the foundational physicists that i've so
far been
talked to have come up with is is
always the same
so and rather than positioning that for
some funny reason something exists and
all the other things do not exist
maybe existence is the default
so
for some uh
funny reason the universe is not set up
as our intuition says that
basically nothing exists by itself by
default and then something needs to be
brought into existence somehow from
first principles the an easier
explanation is to reduce this depth is
to say that well just everything exists
and we have to now explain why something
don't seem to be the case
and so what would it mean for something
to exist in in my understanding for
something to exist it needs to be
implemented
and i i would say that
many things only exist to an approximate
degree
so for instance um this cup here exists
to a very good approximate degree right
it's a certain idea that i can project
consistently in the universe that gives
me certain affordances and it's stable
for a pretty long time and they're
well-defined conditions for the most
part for when this model falls apart and
i can no longer treat this as a cup
and
for instance when it breaks or when my
ability to interact with it breaks or
when the local physical continuum breaks
in such a way that the parts no longer
neatly assemble into a cup and so on
right so there are certain boundary
conditions where the cupness would no
longer hold but for the most part the
cup is very stable if i take rationality
as an object become slightly more fishy
or if i take my own personal identity as
an object
my own existence it becomes superficial
because
to which degree do i really stably exist
and to which degree is this a fiction
that i conveniently maintain to be able
to reason about myself over extended
time spans and i think that i probably
don't exist in to the same
degree of solidity as the cup exists i'm
much more approximate i'm much more like
a voice in the wind blowing through the
mountains
my existence is much more virtual and
vague
and approximate than the existence of
the cup itself
if i go back to this notion of why there
is something rather than nothing and all
these things that can be implemented
exist that cup is implemented in physics
to to a
tighter degree than i am implemented in
physics i'm much more approximately
implemented
i would say that
what can be implemented are ultimately
finite automata it's also the only part
of mathematics that works that's
the implication of goodwill's discovery
that we have to go away from stateless
mathematics and instead what we get are
automata and we cannot define infinity
without running into contradictions in
the languages in which we do it
you mentioned that there are many
different ways to define logic and
different logics ultimately they come
down to the same thing that was also
part of this big discovery that we made
in the 20th century that all the ways in
which we can define logic and
computation and so on are
the same
they have all the same power
so the turing machine and the post
machine and the lambda calculus and the
combinators and boolean logic
and specific programming languages and
the different approaches to define
constructive mathematics turn out to be
equivalent
there are some
tight small elements at the boundaries
and so on where we could uh get into
debates but by and large uh they
all turn out to be uh
there's mappings between these systems
and these mappings can all happen in
polynomial time or in constant time and
so it's not so bad
the logic can be solved if you look at
geometry there is not this question oh
my god there is not just euclidean
geometry but there's also non-euclidean
geometry these are not fundamentally
different it's just that the
non-occlusion geometry relaxes one of
the conditions which means the space in
which geometry takes place doesn't need
to be flat the space can have curvature
or it can be we can go beyond this and
it can be very irregular and so on
and it turns out that geometry is the
mathematics of too many parts to count i
think
so as soon as we have too many parts to
count uh the way in which we can perform
uh calculations is that we need to
identify operators that converge in the
limit which means if you have trillions
of parts and you add one more part the
result doesn't change perceptively in
any way right and this is uh when you
have something where you converge
approximately against infinity when you
have approximate continuity
and the set of operators that converge
in the limit when you have too many
parts to count this is practically what
we mean by geometry
so it's a particular way to model words
that are made of too many parts to keep
track of the individual parts
and of course our brain is largely
confronted with the world at such a
level where there are too many atoms to
count too many molecules too many people
to count
too many uh
dollars to count and so on and so we
treat them as continuous values and we
look at the limit dynamics and we have
geometric models
um two points the the first is um i i'm
not going to make arguments about uh the
interrelations of logic i i was making
an argument that kant took something to
be a priori he didn't know everything
you just said and so his judgments about
what was the priority were incorrect
it's plausible that
that's also the case for us
and so that's all i meant to say about
that um i want to go back to the cup and
me
um or the cup and you um because it
seems to me given your ontology and your
epistemology the cup is and i think
you're saying that the cup is a fiction
as well um and so you're a fiction the
cup is a fiction
and yet the physics seems to not be
fictional for you
and yet i don't know how we get to the
physics without objects like cups and
people like you and i uh the physics is
generated by people like you and i using
instruments that are like microscopes
and whatever that are just like the cup
um and therefore
how do all these fictional beings using
fictional devices come up with the
physics that is really the case
it seems to me
that
you need to say that the objects and the
people doing the science are as as real
as the science itself
um and that
would tend to say that the cup has a
kind of reality to it um
and you have a kind of reality to it
that are have to be assumed for the
practice of physics itself that's that's
what i was trying to say now you may be
saying
physics doesn't have an ontology for
cups
i totally get that
what i'm saying is why should physics
have the monopoly on our ontology what's
the argument for that given the
epistemology and the the psychology that
you're advancing here it seems to me
like our ontology is much more rich
than our current physics is capable
of incorporating
that's what i'm trying to get at uh for
example um you you said you're not as
stable as the cup well you sort of have
to be i mean
there has to be a continuity in you
there's a right
as i move around the object it's not
just that i have to find a continuity in
the object there has to be a continuity
in me as a knower in order for the
stability of that object to be possible
i also have to
have some kind of continuity
i again i'm trying to get at
well
because
sorry uh
we got into this and and maybe we both
uh have taken each other too far afield
uh we got into this because i asked you
just like what you you
were dealing with uh you know the
dualism problem that descartes gave us
and then you said there isn't a problem
because it's all sort of
i heard you saying sort of all
constructed in the mind
but then if it's all constructed in the
mind so is all the things and all the
tools by which we did the physics
like i would be
let's use your analogy
the physics i wouldn't trust the physics
i'm doing in a dream if i knew it was a
dream
and if i know it's a simulation which
you were claiming
why should i trust the physics
that are occurring within that
simulation it seems to me that there is
an ontology richer than physics that is
needed in order to make the kind of
arguments you're making
so uh first of all don't worry you don't
need to apologize for taking us too far
afield that can take us back it's no
issue if we feel that we are going too
far out here there are two ways in which
i can
experience physics one is in a lucid
dream for instance i can test whether
i'm in dream or not usually for instance
by operating a light switch i found that
in lucid dreams late switches for the
most part don't work
it's a funny thing but they don't
another thing is when you read the uh
text on a page
uh it's difficult to read the same text
twice
you might have noticed this in dreams
right and this seems to be a limitation
of the way in which our working memory
works so i suspect that the lucid dream
has to store all its state in working
memory and the causal structure that is
stable in the dream has to be held there
and as the limit to how many bits can be
held in our working memory and as a
result the complexity of the physics
simulation in our own dream
is limited
and this means that when we want to have
a physics simulation that is more
detailed we probably need to have state
that is stored outside of our mind for
practical reasons it's not a
philosophical argument it's just
practical observation so if you want to
experience a world in which light
switches work you need to store some
state outside of your working memory
in in the in some substrate that is
outside of your mind and this could be a
physical room so for practical purposes
if you ever find yourself in the
situation that you need to figure out
whether you are dreaming this or not you
could uh try
uh
to rely on processes the environment and
test for the existence of process
environment that you need to update a
lot of state to be stable and you check
for the stability of the state of course
there could still be some kind of
conspiracy going on so this is not
foolproof if an evil scientist is
messing with you then the evil scientist
might be able to change your memories of
what just happened and or might be
interjecting
weird things in there but the question
that we want to answer on the other
level is is there a conspiracy going on
and the idea that is underlying physics
is not complicated assumptions about the
notion of energy time space and
causality and so on these are all
things that we infer at some level
they're not assumptions that we need to
presuppose to make physics work the
basic
assumption in physics is maybe there is
no conspiracy
maybe this is just mechanical and we
have to understand why that is the case
and uh the
idealist assumption is there is a
conspiracy we do live in a simulation
and uh this idealism is not solving
anything in a way that uh physics is not
solving it
you still have to if you want to explain
what's going on uh and make a claim that
you now understand how the universe
works how that conspiracy could possibly
work and explaining the conspiracy is
intrinsically harder
if you deny the possibility of any kind
of physics
and physics just being the mechanical
explanation
i'll come back to the point of i
i don't know if we infer certain things
or our inferences presuppose them we can
come back to that in a minute um
but but i mean we're in a position at
least that's what i hear you saying
different from descartes right person
being
uh
you know beset by the dick the cartesian
demon because
i hear you saying
i know that i'm in a simulation
which is precisely what can't happen so
i i i agree i'm excluding
the the cartesian demon for because as
you say there's no way out of that that
well right if if i doubt my compa i'm
doubting whether or not my doubt is like
you can just fall forever and ever i get
that i i'm not saying that
what i'm saying is though but you you
we're we're not in that
i
you seem to be saying and i i think i
agree with you we're not in that
position we can we can come to see
what is it about
our uh our consciousness and our
perception that is not real but for me
that means that our consciousness and
our perception
and our intelligence also have access to
reality have an ability to pick up on
what's real because that would be the
only thing i could use to contrast uh
with like my subjective experience right
in order to say i know that i'm inside
something i have to be able to give you
good reason for believing there's
something outside of me
right and that that that outside of me
also has to have access
um i know i'm not saying direct access
i'm not a naive empiricist it has to
have access to my consciousness and my
reason or my intelligence or again i
can't actually posit the very model that
i'm using to say that everything is a
projection
yeah so if we try to understand this
situation to me it's very uh
it's almost capable to have in a similar
situation as a robot living inside of
some kind of computer and this
computer is set up in such a way that it
provides affordances to an external
environment and now uh the uh
computational system that lives inside
of that computer uh this set of
organized patterns that we call software
is set up in such a way that it can
discover regularities and the patterns
and extend its affordances into this
environment and and thereby make sense
of the environment and it seems to me
that i am uh
i find myself in arrangement that is
indistinguishable from this description
that is intimately familiar to me if i'm
an ai researcher
right i guess the question i'm asking
you in your example is it possible for
the robot to discover that it is inside
the computer
um yes i think it is but uh there are
certain limitations to this and i think
that you can discover this from in a
sense from first principles because
there are no alternatives there are many
uh ways in which you can map this
conceptually so the ways in which you
depict these entities because they are
not entities that are defined by
physical appearances they are not
defined by res extensor they are defined
by certain conceptual relationships
and it turns out that all the ways i
think in which a mind can exist as an
apparent pattern and control structure
are
can be mapped
structurally
in first principles on conceptual
structures that are equivalent so we
just might
disagree about
how this computer is set up this is the
von neumann architecture or anything
else and there is no possible way to
distinguish them and there is no claim
to this uh how this actually works we
know that the biological systems that
are able to process information work in
uh
dramatically different ways from the
technological systems that we have built
to process information and so on and we
don't have disagreement about this but
we also know that uh there is a certain
deep conceptual level and equivalence of
what they can do
i agree with that and so now it's
what it sounds like you're saying is
um
the
the the most real things are the things
that are sort of accessible to my priori
reason and that that's what i use in
order to determine
i'm within the welter of experience and
i use my apriori ability to make sense
of things and that helps me sort through
and sift through um those that are going
to
let me know that i'm inside a simulation
um and then that that says to me
that
what's ultimately real for you and you
invoke the archetypes at one point when
you talk about the cop you said you're
you're you're sounding to me like a
platonus you sound to me like you're
saying what's ultimately real
are sort of the mathematical objects
accessible throughout prior reality and
everything else is less real than them
and it's like i mean plato has the first
simulation theory around you're inside
the cave and you're only looking at the
shadows and the echoes and you have to
make your way out
is that a fair reading
almost i think that an archetype is an
optimum and a description function
it's in some sense a mathematical
regularity in the same sense as the
greek gods are archetypes personality
archetypes that basically if you take a
space of personality properties and
their interaction
right they
interact with each other and you
basically
find settings of the dials that give you
one personality that is as clear as
possible sure given these assumptions
you end up with one of these archetypes
and it's how the greek gods are stable
in in this way or the christian god is
the archetype of the total god yeah and
it's a particular one because this thing
needed to be loaded to be also a
civilizational spirit for an
agricultural society
so it's not actually the total god and
that's the slate of hand that is going
on by identifying the creator god uh
with the god of meaning and with the god
of the uh late roman empire right so
these are different gods in a certain
way that have been put into one uh for
practical reasons
and uh the reason why we have so many
claims to total gods uh is because of
this payload that the miss of the total
god has to carry but uh this doesn't
mean that the archetype actually exists
out in the physical world there is no
reason why when you have a description
function and you discover an optimum on
it why this
thing needs to exist but it will exist
in any systems that build these types of
models which means they exist as a point
of reference there's a certain optima in
which you describe things and it's also
true for our own perception when we
perceive things what we perceive is not
the features in which they are arranged
what we perceive as a certain ideal that
is being projected by the features
right yeah and this is uh this is what
platonism means it doesn't mean a claim
to the actual existence of physical
things of or uh
affairs in in the world with which we
causally interact uh it's uh the
observation that when we are building
models of the world there are certain
models that are more pure and more
elegant than others right and this uh
this is in some sense the platonic idea
yeah and so that's where you and i have
a very deep kind of agreement um
uh because i i consider myself a
neoplatonist
in my sort of ultimate orientation
i guess what i would say
and plato i think might agree with me is
he would say well saying it doesn't
exist physically it doesn't say much
because the physics is ultimately less
real
than uh the platonic objects of which uh
right because the physical things the
instantiated things are only as you said
only temporary instances right they're
less stable they're less real and so the
fact that it doesn't exist physically
doesn't sound
like to plato's ears they would go yeah
and that's that's to say that they're
more real
than a physical reality in an important
way um and that seems to me
kind of what you need in order to do
science
you need to be able to posit these kinds
of entities in order to do
generalizations
in
in order to uh be audacious in some ways
the empiricists wouldn't like the fact
that i could run some math and make
conclusions about reality i mean you you
have to believe
uh uh like stronger you have to assert
this kind of thing um and now i
um you seem to be nodding so i don't
think i'm being too imposing on you and
i'm finding that we got to this place
very very interesting because and i want
and i don't mean this as any kind of
critique of your presentation
i didn't get that when i was watching
your videos right it took it it took it
took a lot of this no and again i'm not
critiquing you but i i found that i've
now gotten to a very very interesting
place with you um i i don't know what uh
we haven't said too much about
consciousness and meaning like we
promised we would but i found this uh
this progression really really powerful
and interesting um
because i'm also interested
um
you have a knack for saying very
intriguing things about religion and
history um i'm very interested
in the fact that platonism neoplatonism
because they were a continuity uh formed
an interesting kind of lingua
intellectual lingua franca along the
silk road uh you can even see this
historically uh neoplatonism was able to
reciprocally reconstruct with
christianity
uh with islam
with judaism and there's there's now
some evidence even with buddhism it
seems to have this interesting capacity
to be
more of a er or primordial
representation of our shared
intelligibility making processes i find
that a very interesting proposal
right now
because if we could get the
philosophical argument we've been
exploring and the historical argument
together
that means
we could make a plausible argument for a
shareable
framework for interpreting uh reality
and making and making claims about
reality and normative judgments and i
think this is very centrally needed
for a problem i talk about extensively
which is the meaning crisis
that the west is facing so i just wanted
to say i i mean i've been sort of like
very critical but i want to now stand
back and express appreciation uh for
sort of where we got to and some of the
possibilities i see in it now i hope
that also wasn't uh imposing on you but
you were nodding as i was saying it so
it seemed like it was
and that you don't need to apologize in
this way in any way i don't identify
with me having these ideas
i can observe myself having ideas but
the relationship that the ideas have to
me is not very interesting i just try to
play the glass punch wheel as well as i
can as you do as do you right so you
never need to apologize for criticizing
an idea or having a different one or uh
pointing out where my thinking falls
short i'm i'm grateful if you point out
things that appear to be inconsistent so
don't worry about this at all
fair enough you're playing you're
playing you're playing the music with me
very well and i appreciate that my point
for making the apology first of all i'm
a canadian we apologize for everything
secondly uh the point for me was to
trying to show you from where i was
coming that i wasn't that was the point
i was trying i was trying to make um
so i'm i'm interested
can i ask you a question
it's slightly more personal um
i think it's fair to say that the
position you've taken
because i've i've interacted with a lot
of cognitive scientists who are computer
scientists the position you've taken
isn't
like
isn't the consensus position or even the
majority position
is that fair to say uh
yes and no i find that uh a lot of
people who deeply think about these
topics seem to be converging so if i
would be discussing with say people like
uh
minsky dasher
many many other people next thursday
will have a discussion about attention
with michael graciano and
vasudev and jonathan cohen who come from
ai and neuroscience and
cognitive science or philosophy
and we've been discussing attention and
its relationship to consciousness
ultimately yeah and i find that there is
a large convergence in these ideas i
also don't find that my ideas are in the
deep sense original it's just that uh
the more ideas i discover the smaller
the parties become that i am late to
uh
you know what i mean right so i i don't
think that's possible to have
philosophical ideas about the
relationship between mind and physical
universe that have not been had by
somebody a few thousand years ago and if
somebody has a fundamentally new idea
that's probably bad news
unless it relates to some kind of super
modern physics in a highly original way
and uh it's possible that we find
discover something on this level but by
and large um the big foundational
questions about epistemology and so on
are a parent for so long that i don't
have any claims to originality in there
and
so
i would say that my ideas are not
original and they are also relatively
widespread
and the disagreements are largely
happening i think at the
when people have different epistemology
when they think that there are ways to
establishing truths that are different
from the ways in which i think that
truth can be established sure sure sure
i i think that's why i wanted to play at
the epistemological ontological level
with you i'm interested though that
because i also have a sense
of
of a growing convergence um
and
that's why i liked the fact that you do
a big picture cog in science because i
think you have to do big picture
cognitive science to get that sense to
to really get it um
and and
i i'm wondering um
in your practice of doing cognitive
science
how do you deal
because i agree with you about that
convergence and i agree with you
how do you deal with you know the um
the different ontologies right so the
neuroscientist talks about neurons and
does fmri
and
the artificial intelligence person talks
about programs and runs simulations and
hoping that they become instantiations
the psychologist talks about working
memory
and does you know experiments on
behavior the linguist talks about deep
structures
and right collects data about judgments
of grammaticality
how do you
this question really concerns me because
i think it it's part of
again
trying to turn cognitive science back
towards the existential issue that's
facing us i don't mean existential a
sense of threat i mean like how
kirkegaard would use the word
existential the meaning making i go back
to the point i made
at the very beginning
right
that for a long time
the cognitive sciences and i'll use that
plural as opposed to cognitive science
that tries to do a synoptic integration
the cognitive scientists the cognitive
sciences have promoted a fragmentation
of what mind means in a profound way
and that fragmentation
has right really when people start to
reflect and
they can offer i see this in my students
right they'll get caught up on i don't
know what this i don't know what a mind
is because there's this there's this
cacophony of all and and then of course
if i don't know what a mind is i don't
know what i am and i don't know how i
relate to the world you can see where
this goes the fragmentation of the
ontology by the cognitive scientists um
is not separate from a lot of
the
the the the suffering that people have
because they don't find a stable
framework in which to locate the
phenomena of mind so
i'm asking this because as i said i
and you invoked wisdom a while back and
so i wanted to circle back to that
what wisdom have you
acquired cultivated realized i don't
know what verb you want um
for helping
do this
get
two things getting the various
disciplines to start to pursue
integration
rather than fragmentation
and connecting that to
sort of the general issue of
how we as embodied minded beings fit
into a scientific worldview i know
that's a big question but i i'm really
interested in it
i think that the disciplines by and
large are not very well incentivized to
do
science and philosophy yeah so
that's something that we need to
understand that there are institutions
in which people go to work to feed their
children
and
a scientist is in some sense to me
someone who
has a particular kind of personality
it's someone who very early on in their
psychological development has decided to
trust their analytical thinking more
uh than their intuitions than their
feelings and their emotions and so on
and typically this happens because they
had asperger's and uh the prayers that
they had when they interacted uh with
other people socially failed in school
and so at some point they realized i
cannot trust my feelings because if i go
by my intuitions my interactions with
the world are going to fail and i have
to move to the analytical mode to make
sense of the world and if you are
permanently in the analytical mode
that's a trauma mode right
and healthy human being should
understand that the purpose of
analytical reasoning which by itself is
very brittle is to go to deal with your
darkest emotions those where you don't
see clearly what's what and in which way
to go so analytical reasoning is a very
powerful tool for very narrow areas of
understanding the world and wealth
happen to be the ones that should be
studied in the sciences but it's wrong
to present scientists as a lifestyle
archetype and as the goal of education
only a very small subset of people
should be scientists and the existence
of scientists is very useful to the
world but being a scientist is largely
not fun
and so we
have see science currently as more like
an employment program where we put
people that are difficult to employ in
the industry because we don't need that
many people in the industry and teach
them methods and then they apply these
methods and we hope that the results
accumulate and the outcome is largely
not that interesting because you're not
being hired into a science to answer
foundational questions there are very
few
ways to answer foundation questions
because the lohang fritz fruits have
been
wrapped long ago
and
so you don't actually need that many
people working in the foundational
disciplines and making foundational
progress
and you're not incentivized to have
ideas about foundational things so among
the very few people that are willing to
offer answer to foundational questions
and are so
bold and crazy to do this
there seem to be in some sense three
groups
one of these groups is people that don't
fully understand the depths of these
questions and think that they found a
very simple answer that solves the
problem without actually doing so
these people tend not to be very
interesting and so there are simplified
notions of consciousness that do not
explain the necessary insufficient
conditions for a system being conscious
and they might lead to models in
neuroscience or in ai or in robotics
that claim to do a certain thing but
they don't
and it's not that interesting that these
exist then there is another type of mind
that is very humble and these people say
i don't actually know what the answer is
and i have the following questions and
i'm aware of the following space of
attempts to answer this and i am
currently moving in this area of the
space and this is what i'm seeing from
where i'm currently standing and this is
how i'm able to interact with others
from this vantage point and
i'm still in this exploration
and
so it's a very tentative position and so
on and it's one that's also not being
openly discussed very much because a
scientist has to publish the things that
they can hope to prove and not the
things that they are seeing and most of
the things that we are seeing as a
possibility and most of the interesting
answers on the realm of the possible
cannot be established by an experiment
because it's a possibility right so the
possibility is often the most
interesting things and possibilities are
difficult to publish and discuss about
exactly well said
and the third group are the crazies
these are people that think that they
have certainty and they're super smart
and they go very deep
and uh often the crazies are also among
the most interesting ones but it also
means that you have to parse them in the
right way yeah so the crazies are in for
instance jurgen schmidt uber or stephen
wolfram and so on these are people that
uh for some reason aspire to greatness
and force themselves to be great no
matter the personal cause to them so
they're not humble
and they do have theories of everything
that they are not shy to denote as such
and put out there and these ideas are
often extremely interesting to bounce up
against and try to understand them
deeply
that's very interesting
much in that was well said
um i've been trying to talk about and
model a form of interaction um called
dialogos in which people are in the
second group but are willing to talk
about sort of ideas and proposals that
come from the third group that where
people are very open uh to
uh as you said a kind of humble
exploration uh uh a an idea that you can
help me correct
and i can help you self-correct and we
can work together and we can get we can
get to ideas that uh emerge between us
that i can't get to on my own you can't
get to on your own um and and that
openness to the possibility of genuine
emergence
bumps us up against what you called them
the crazies
because you one of the things you want
to do is let some of those uh crazier
ideas in because
um
they help
give you it's like letting in a
different sensei into the dojo for a bit
not for not for very long because uh the
dojo will fall apart but letting them in
for a bit because you get a new you get
a new conceptual vocabulary a new
theoretical grammar and so i've been i
i've been trying to model
that uh process even
in an academic setting i've been trying
to
pursue the presentation of ideas about
consciousness the self etc in a
dialogical manner rather than in a
monologue in which there's all kinds of
claims about closure and certainty
so
i think
i agree with you i think that this is
ultimately or at least not ultimately
deeply an institutional issue
and institutions only change when there
are alternative examples of attractive
forms new forms of practice and so i've
been trying to bring this new form of
practice into the forefront as a way of
trying to
address a lot of the concerns usage
brought up so
i think that
spending time
doing more of this
is actually not it's not an ornament
it's not just a ceremony it's not just a
social gathering for cognitive science
it's actually essential for cognitive
science if it's going to progress i
guess this is me also saying uh thank
you to kurt for doing this and thank you
also for you you know you came here in
good faith and you've been uh that way
throughout but i'm trying to make an
argument for this being more central and
the problem
is that the institution that is
where we house the science the
university doesn't know how to deal with
this emerging phenomena it doesn't know
how to deal with because of social media
because of this technology because a lot
of this understanding this is all
happening more and more and more
but when i for example when i try to
bring this into the institution the
institution seems to still be bound in
sort of a victorian paper and pencil
mentality about how we evaluate things
how we evaluate the work people are
doing like for example none of this even
though i think it's really important
to the to the life of cognitive science
none of this would even show up on my cv
uh because if i put it on my cv it would
just be ignored um and it seems to me
that's a very problematic place that we
have gotten and we've gotten to
john what would be an example of you
bringing this idea of dialogue to the
university and the university saying no
like what specifically did you propose
so for example i i you know i i put out
i put out a series the elusive eye with
greg enriquez and christopher
matripietro on the nature and function
of the self it did untangling the world
not with greg enriquez a psychologist
about consciousness and it was done like
uh did one with uh zach stein and greg
enriquez on towards a metapsychology
that is true to transformation and to my
mind the kind of exploration of ideas
and advancement of insightful arguments
was better there and i'm not trying to
be self-congratulatory because other
people are doing this but it is better
than a lot of the stuff that is
typically
site like you typically put on your cv
to count as
right that you're doing work in the
discipline uh you know
you know
you know
that's that's what i'm trying to say
the discipline is no longer the place
where the science is getting mo sorry
that was exactly the wrong word the
institution the university is no longer
the and i like working for the
university of toronto by the way i'm not
trying to get myself out of a job but
right the the like the institution is
not the place
really
where the kind of science we need now
both for itself and both for the culture
is happening that's the argument i'm
making
yoshi but there is no other place right
it's not like that there is a new heaven
that has opened itself up for
experiments and thoughts like this there
is a network of
basically small events of workshops
conferences and so on that happens
between the disciplines but it's mostly
that we do this on the side yes we do
that in addition to uh what we do in the
sciences in the same way as michael uh
graciano
or uh tononi and many others basically
have a daytime job in the sciences
and the philosophical contributions that
they do they do on the site it's also in
many ways too fast
and it's not uh that we feel that or i
feel that i'm mistreated in this way i
understand why the institutional
incentives are in the way they are and
the reasonable and uh good-natured
reasons for this for the most part for
why this is the way in which it is it
just means that we need alternate ways
of funding uh to make this happen and we
need an alternate ways of organizing it
to
keep on
with going it
is going on with it i also want to uh
just briefly make a case for the crazies
the reason why i'm not a crazy is
because i'm not smart enough i'm not
smart enough to maintain the illusion
that i see things that others are not
seeing and often more clearly and better
and with more focus than i can see them
so uh i basically i get humbled by my
own inadequacy and there are some people
which are basically not that inadequate
so for them it takes many decades longer
before they would get to the point where
they are forced to humble themselves so
they can
maintain an illusion of greatness that
they might have developed in their
dollar sense as a protective measure for
their own psychology and keep up with
being great and if somebody who's really
really smart is able to keep up the
crazy greatness this notion of everybody
else is confused and basically the only
one who sees the solution and here it is
basically uh this is an extremely
valuable person to have around and they
should be
cherished and protected and
it doesn't mean that you have to believe
everything that they say but they're
very few people which are so bold and so
daring that they sacrifice themselves in
such a way yoshi do you see that as a
negative
because the way that i hear it it sounds
like you know when you're at a job
interview and they say so what are your
weaknesses you say i work too hard so
what are your weaknesses well i'm not
beset by the illusions of the crazies
uh i wouldn't it says present this as a
weakness the typical
answer in this job interview would be
i'm too honest
right and then the other one says
why is that a problem don't give a [ __ ]
what you think
now the problem is when you are in a job
interview and you don't fit in the issue
is
what is the thing that you actually want
to do do you want to be part of that
particular hierarchy of this particular
kind of organization of this particular
kind of normativity and do you think
that you can actually help it along do
you share the aesthetics of that place
of work
that you will be part of and i found
when i was in academia i really enjoyed
it i really enjoyed working with
students i found that i needed to defend
a space of inquiry and the space of
inquiry ex co-existed with the
application of methods it was this thing
that enabled me to say to a student that
was not inspired you shouldn't be here
in my class if you don't like this if
you don't intrinsically want to do this
you're wasting your own time and
attention and my time and attention and
the time and attention of everybody
who's there go have a relationship go
read a good book go sit down in a cafe
or watch a movie or go to another class
don't be here because what we try to do
is we try to abuse the machine of
academia to do the things that we
actually want to do which is try to
figure out our relationship to the world
and make actual intellectual uh and
philosophical and personal progress on
certain questions that actually move us
that motivate us to be here and spend a
portion of our precious irretrievable
lifetime
with each other
on these problems
and
so i don't found it difficult to defend
but i also understand that the machines
that we are part of that we are serving
are largely serving other goals
that was very well said
i guess for me i want to
i guess i i i see more urgency now than
there has been in the past i agree with
you about these institutions are set up
the way they are for good reasons etc uh
but
i i do think we are we're entering into
very very significant changes um
you and i both think that
you know
strong ai is something that's very
possible i know you said because you've
said this and you and i both think this
has you know just important
ramifications beyond what a lot of
people are thinking about
uh and
that's just one example of the way in
which
this is
accelerating and
uh and
and is corrosive to
people's attempt to sift through
and make sense sift through the [ __ ]
and make sense of their world um uh the
work i did on the meeting crisis
the the sense of [ __ ]
it's accelerating it's accelerating
exponentially people are increasingly
thinking there's more and more more and
more [ __ ] and more [ __ ] around
um and
i think the kind of stuff we're doing
here together
is the place the arena the dojo in which
we both train
how to wrestle with that
and exemplify how to wrestle with that
and so i think there's an urgency uh
now
to get i think covet accelerated it in
certain ways to give more prominence to
this dialogue this kind of biological
space and practice um
so i guess for me uh
i want to push
i want to push for more of this
uh because
the
the rates of suffering both in the sense
of distress and loss of agency uh seem
to be going up by several sort of
objective march of markers and so i'm
concerned
that
i don't think
i don't think the academic world qua
academic world is turning to this
problem and i think this is a better
forum in which
we can start to explore what we need to
do
in order to address that problem so for
me that urgency
is
part of what i was trying to put my
finger on when i said
we need to be doing more of this this is
valuable this is central this shouldn't
be on the sidelines it should be in the
center and and and there's difficult
tasks there's very practical tasks of
how do we make this more attractive to a
wider audience of people um
and how how do we make it attractive so
we can draw some of the first kind of
people
in and how do we make it attractive so
that
we don't automatically exclude the
crazies um i agree uh with that i mean
but you don't want you don't want you
don't want just suck you don't want a
room you're filled with just socrates a
bunch of socrates uh he was at boss he
didn't fit in and they killed him um
and so um
i think these for me
these questions are are are becoming
increasingly central about how do we
make
this what we're doing here
into an attractive way of life
uh for people what do you mean by way of
life
so what i mean by this is that uh
and i think you said that like
for me
exploring these ideas is not something i
do to get sort of an intellectual orgasm
and oh that was cool
right
ultimately i i want to
be able to explore these ideas in a way
that can
ameliorate
people's sense of being disconnected
from themselves from the world
from each other
and so
if i get a deeper understanding of the
mind
and consciousness
and meaning
i want to i want that to ultimately be
in service of helping people
to whatever they they feel comfortable
with and capable of
of making use of these ideas
in
translating
them into practices
things that they do to individually and
collectively to make better sense
like let's use a let's use a a model uh
a historical right christianity and i'm
not a i'm not a christian i'm not
proselytizing for it was able to create
this structure that went from like
aquinas to somebody's grandmother and
got you you get them to interact
together coordinate together uh work
together have a shared sense of
connectedness
meaning
um that's the kind of thing i think we
need i'm not proposing a religion here i
sometimes say i'm proposing a religion
that's not a religion that's what i'm
talking about kurt i'm talking about
the the these
in the end
sorry this sounds harsh but in the end i
don't really care deeply about what you
believe i care about what you practice
i care about how are you transforming
yourself and how are you affording other
people to transform themselves in a way
that makes lives less beset by
foolishness
more
enhanced by wisdom
and and and flourishing for individuals
that's what i'm that's what i ultimately
care about
did that answer your question yeah what
would happen if that goal of
helping people
contradicted the goal of let's say
investigating reality whatever that
means
so for example let's say you found out
some truth via some scientific
investigation that would destabilize
people that would make them feel worse
that would disconnect us so then
what do you do you make the decision to
not publish that to not investigate that
further
um i i
i guess my response to that is
um i ha i have a certain kind of
confidence
in the true the interconnection between
things being true
and then ultimately being good
in fact
we have to view truth as a kind of good
in order to explain what we're doing as
scientists um there's something about
look you know nasdaq's experience
machine right here let me give you an
example from i do this in my classroom
i ask people how many of you are in
satisfying romantic relationships
romantic relationships are really
important in our culture because they
sort of take the role of religion
right um and because you ask people what
do you need to be happy romantic
relationship and what causes you the
most suffering romantic relationships so
right
and i ask how many of you are in
satisfying romantic relationships
and then you know i get a certain
percentage i said of these people
how many of you would want to know that
your partner was cheating on you even if
that meant the destruction of the
relationship 95 of the people keep their
hand up
there's there's there's a there's a
there's a valuing a meaning of being
connected to what's real
that seems to be this is one of plato's
arguments that seems to be kind of a
meta desire
in addition to whatever we desire we
have a meta desire that what satisfies
that desire is real
in some fashion which is why i was
pressing on realness so much with yoshi
so well what i want to say is um there's
a presumption in your question
that
right
there isn't an intrinsic value or
goodness to
uh discovering what's real and i think
there is um and then what
can people
transform themselves because so they
come into greater conformity to that
yeah that's what i think it means to
cultivate wisdom
and so i put i sort of put my
trust not in the particular metaphysics
of the wisdom traditions but the fact
that we've had wisdom traditions
and we have
reliably found people to become
people to be capable of becoming wiser
and certain individuals to be wiser than
others
so what i'm saying it i have i put faith
in those two things together that's what
i'm saying
yoshi i was going to ask if you have any
comments on that
yeah we found that we joined and meet
don't have differences at least not in
the
discussion that we had in the last
couple hours we mostly had very similar
approaches and ideas and we developed
our terms together in ways that was very
harmonic
we might have a difference in the reason
why we do things it seems to me that
john has a different relationship to
normativity than me and maybe we can go
into this question later but basically
from my perspective looks like john sees
himself as a spiritual teacher
and i don't have enough
maturity to see myself as a spiritual
teacher with integrity i also don't know
what i would get out of this my
own observation of the meaning crisis is
that it's inevitable because the
civilization that we are part of doesn't
have much of a future
and
there is no way in which the
civilization can be fixed without
changing some of its core assumptions
and
so uh we sense this and we it's
reflected in the fact that our
civilization is not projecting itself
into the future we have no models that
we discuss with our children in school
or in our institutions we have no plans
that go beyond the next few decades it's
not that we actually think about what
will life on earth look like for our
civilization in 500 years from now
and that's new
this was not true in in the christian
society for instance they had an idea of
what was going to happen in a few
hundred years from then and this idea
might have been wrong but they made
plans for it and some of these plans
came to pass and we don't have that kind
of planning horizon anymore so we
basically are now in an organism as a
hyper organism uh that is past its prime
that is in some sense visibly in its
autumn and that is
uh facing off against all sorts of
existential risks and we feel helpless
at dealing with these risks and as a
result we don't have a shared purpose we
might have a shared purpose as an
individual with a family with children
with friends but we don't seem to
project this shared purpose anymore at a
societal level and there are only small
groups within the societies some
evangelical cults and transhumanist
skulls and so on that try to maintain
the fiction of a future that they're
acting with but not at the level of the
entire civilization it is the level of
this individual group
and our mainstream uh geist deals with
this mostly by uh despair or denial yes
and uh or even an outright nihilism
and i don't have an argument against
that nihilism because i think that from
the perspective of the
civilizational hive mind this justified
and if we want to build something new we
have to do this from the vantage point
of the next civilization and that's
almost impossible to maintain the space
in your own mind what the next
civilization would be looking like and
how to build it
so the only thing that i have to offer
in terms of spiritual guidance is that i
hug my friends
and uh
there's not that much more and uh and so
it's more
when we know the possibility that i
could offer somebody that i say this is
how you fix your life this is how you
fix your relationship to the world this
is how you fix your relationship to
society and this is how you fix your
society itself because they don't have
these kinds of answers i don't know what
these answers would look like i'm
willing to look for them i'm willing to
look for them with others but i'm not
convinced that there is an answer
and instead there is more place that we
can get to in this place comes from
attempt to develop integrity and to be
truthful and i agree with john that
truth is crucial because truth is
instrumental to good regulation it's
even reflected in cybernetics in the
good regulator theorem you cannot
uh regulate reality when you're not
truthful about it so the attempt to bend
your worldview to make it more desirable
to deny the things that don't fit into
the world that you prefer as the just
one and so on is not going to lead to a
better world it's going to lead to a
world that is worse
and so you need when you want to model
the world do this in a space that is
independent of what you want to be true
so there need to be two parts of us one
that is modeling the world this
detachment
it's not important who is looking at the
world and why
and another one where you make your
personal bets and where you construct
your aesthetics based on what you think
is true
and
this separation is something that is not
a consensus in the uh disciplines that
think about what the world should be
looking like so for instance there are
very few sociologists that look at the
world with detachment they largely do
this from a very local perspective that
is congruent with what their friends
think and that is basically
characterized by their present ideology
and i don't think that you can be
ideological and truthful at the same
time where the allergy
commits you to seeing the certain way of
the things that are happening in the
world regardless of the facts
that you are observing and it makes you
inclined to pick certain facts over
others to support this particular kind
of aesthetic
and for me the aesthetic is something
that needs to be developed independently
of the reasoning about what is the case
and since the most people that think
normatively prefer to be part of the
hivemind before they are truthful
autonomously i have difficulty with the
general notion of normativity my own
thinking is when i do philosophy
primarily not normative
i'm thinking about everything that could
be the case i'm not thinking about what
should be the case every shoot is an if
then
um
there's a lot i i have in agreement with
about uh what you said there uh about
the meaning crisis
um i guess part of
what
i
i don't know if uh
i'm a spiritual teacher or not but uh
but nevertheless um perhaps what i would
say is
i think you were proposing a lot of what
goes into the notion of wisdom
a concern for the truth the ability to
detach from an egocentric perspective uh
pursuing integrity um
etc
and i think it's one of the things we
should do is consider
uh
increasing the wisdom of people
um i think that's a viable project
um and in conjunction with that
um
i
i think we should do what
uh what has typically happened when
civilizations have collapsed uh the
bronze age collapse or perhaps the
collapse of the western roman empire
right you had
you had
the building of new communities
and communities of communities that made
possible new ways of life for people
and were able to
take
uh salvage
what the the
previous civil legislation had done and
exact it into the next civilization a
prototypical example of this is be
somebody like augustine you know the
barbarians are literally at the gate and
he is shepherding
sort of the greco-roman heritage into
christianity and he's modifying it he's
coming up with a new way of being he's
the autobiographical self comes into
kind of awareness
you know there's a new way of being a
person new way of being a community new
way of being in relationship to the
world i'm not saying he did this
single-handedly i'm just using it as a
case and he helps to build uh the
possibilities of the next civilization
now i'm not arrogant i hope i'm not so
arrogant to think and i know i'm
augustine and i know what it is it's
going to be turn up i think we should be
getting a lot of people trying to build
right these models these ways
um because
typically if you have that kind of a
translation
process already in place you get to the
next civilization with much less
suffering um i'm not convinced that
we can like you that we can save this
but we have
um but i guess i want to find out what
is the best way individually and
collectively
of collecting the candles from what we
have made
so that we can carry them into and make
it possible for our children um
and so this is for me a way of trying to
get back
to
the a generational relationship like you
were talking about where it's not just
me here now in distraction or despair
but trying to ask
like and i don't mean this
technologically or sociologically or
politically
trying to ask
look for
where are people trying to build what
looked like viable possible new ways uh
for being in a civilization
and we know that this has been done in
the past
and
this isn't an algorithm it can't be but
we can look at those historical figures
we can look at many of those historical
examples and try and glean sort of the
best lessons possible that's what i'm
proposing i i'm definitely not founding
a religion or anything like that i i i'm
not the right person for the job i don't
want the job and um so
if that's
if that means i see myself as a
spiritual practitioner um so be it i'm
fine with that but i just wanted to
clarify
what i'm proposing i'm i'm proposing
something that is possible at least we
have
i think relevantly similar cases from
history of where this has worked and you
can see it like i say two i've looked at
carefully the axial revolution and also
the end of the western roman empire
that's what i'm proposing that's what
i'm proposing
i have a question for both of you we'll
start with yosha you mentioned that you
have this relationship with your ideas
which is that you don't devote yourself
to them they're not they're tentative
and i'm curious in the past two years
what's an idea that you used to believe
most that you no longer believe and then
what led you to that decision that's for
both of you but we'll start with the
osha
i'm glad he has to go first
so let's say in the most recent past two
years
um but
it usually doesn't feel like a big
revolution it's more a gradual
progression or sometimes a new vista
opens up
and there are a few thoughts that
now are interesting to me that is for
instance how can a system discover
itself in the world that i see more
central than before there are a few
notions that i take to be
possible that i didn't explore before
so uh
something that i'm exploring right now
is for instance the idea of
um
memory not store being stored in
synaptic weights only but being stored
in uh the soma of neurons in the form of
rna
and this leads to a
vertical
change in the way in which i think about
the formation of memory and the
execution of
functions in the brain
and so it's not normative in the sense
that i now believe that we should be
things doing differently but it it
changes the way in which i think about
neural computation and leads me to
envisioning new experiments that need to
be done to figure out whether this is
the case
and
this is an example of where my
perspective has shifted or another one
is uh the role of consciousness
so for instance i
uh
used to think that consciousness might
be a side effect of the way in which
cognition works in human brains
and that other systems that process
information
in the service of agency are not
necessarily conscious
and
while i still consider that to be
possible
i think it's also conceivable that
consciousness at some shape or form is
crucial to make sense of the world
basically perception is following
gradients and it's converging to a
certain state
and if you just follow a grain you don't
even need to have memory of where you're
coming from
but certain kinds of reality
interpretation require construction and
construction cannot follow a gradient
constructor needs to make experiments
and remember which experiments worked
and why and then recall this and use the
knowledge of that so it needs to make
index memories of the operations that it
performed and it also requires some kind
of central organization to construct you
need to develop a central plan and then
act on that central plan so you have
some kind of top-down
localized imposition of a
low-dimensional function on the entirety
of perception
and it could be that this coincides
to the large degree with the
functionality of attentional
consciousness
and basically consciousness in the role
of a government
and the government is an agent that is
imposing an offset on the
payout metrics of individual
participants in the system to make their
nash equilibrium compatible with the
common good so it's basically overcoming
local incentives in the system uh to
follow a larger plan
so this government itself is not
creating the incentives the incentives
are created by game theory physics and
in underlying dynamics of the system
that is facilitating for instance a
society or that is facilitating the
function of your brain you will still
have to look for food and social
interaction in all these things
consciousness is
channeling the motivation that we have
it's not creating it
it's creating a model of uh
where we are this is what we experience
as reality and the experience of model
of what we should be doing these are our
purposes but they are the motive power
in these purposes comes from our
underlying motivation that is outside of
consciousness that is older than
consciousness itself
on the other hand uh we can see that
basically all the mammals are conscious
and this was also something that i was
not that acutely aware of before i
started looking
uh but it seems to be that uh
apparent in the interaction between
animals and also the animals and humans
that there is a mutual awareness of the
awareness of the other
so these are things that my
thinking has changed in the last few
years and in part gradually in part more
radically the most radical one is
rna-based memory transfer the
possibility of that and the implications
for that which is just a very recent
idea that i have i don't know how long
i'll hold on to this and what will come
of this but it's something that
doesn't change my normative thinking in
a fundamental way and often is these
small changes to details of your
technical worldview that can have a big
change in your trajectory
john
it was very cool uh
the consciousness as a government i like
that idea it resonates with some of the
stuff i've been thinking about so maybe
we could talk about that at some point
in the future
um so for me
um
i'm like yoshi i mean i i often i'm
aware of these things only
retrospectively
not prospectively or introspectively um
so i guess retrospectively
i'm noticing that i'm really
i'm focusing on this issue that we
bumped up against a couple of times
which is normativity
and for a longest long time i was very
much
like sort of like the problem that
habermas talks about
i saw these domains the true the good
and the beautiful as separate from each
other and autonomous
um and
and then there was a hard fact value
distinction
uh things like that and i i'm now
um
i'm now really i'm really really
seriously questioning that i'm seeing
more and more good arguments for the
interpenetration of fact and value
and more and more arguments for the
interpenetration mutual affordance of
truth goodness
and beauty
and um
that
is that's opening up
other issues about the interconnection
of affect
and cognition
um
and that and like you show that leads
into more sort of technical things
i think there's ways of integrating
processes of relevance realization
with predictive processing models and i
just reviewed a paper
for frontiers i hope it gets published i
recommend it to get published where
people are exploring this convergence
now
in a really powerful way
uh one of my former students um mark
miller does excellent work around this
and so uh considering a lot of this
stuff
much more deeply so there's the
downstream stuff about
ways in which particular theories could
be integrated together and the upstream
stuff is
maybe
the the the enlightenment
i mean like the european enlightenment
as a period of time
the enlightenment idea of the autonomy
of the normativities is something we
should go back
uh to questioning a lot of the machinery
behind for example the is odd
distinction the fact value distinction
has actually been undermined by a lot of
arguments uh k-sphere has made a good
case of that and others
so i'm not i'm not sure where i am on
that i'm reading some very good books by
diesel schindler about that but i'm
really trying to
get clearer um
about the relationship uh between
uh the true the good and the beautiful
to give the classical name on it and
then what that means about
um
well
being wise how we best live our lives
because talking about how we best live
our lives is a normative judgment and
how do all those three if
they aren't
i mean part of the meaning crisis is
also the fragmentation of these
normativities and we put them into weird
competitions with each other that was
part of harbor moss's argument
and if it's possible that we are moving
beyond that model of the modularity
of the normativities but rather they're
i'm not saying their identity by the way
but their interpenetration and mutual
affordance into affordance
that i think has important implications
for
how people go about judging what it is
to lead
uh the best kind of life um so that's
where my thinking i wasn't in that
position
um
i wasn't tackling those issues
i wasn't
reflecting on them i wasn't reading
about them three or four years ago so
that's
a a significant change for me i had i
had a whole set of presuppositions
and and just don't make this heroic i
didn't sort of like oh by the way
by reading people like those
presuppositions have been slowly
archaeologically excavated
and i've come to be questioning them
in a way that i had not foreseen
and
and that i'm also kind of finding
currently fruitful and valuable
okay so this question comes from
donald hoffman
he wants to know
is space-time an aspect of fundamental
reality
and also can there be a theory of
everything so you can tackle whichever
one you want and we'll start as usual
with yosha
no it's not the
obvious giveaway is that the collapse of
the waveform marks a point in your past
beyond which you cannot obtain a model
of events happening in time and space it
in a pinpointed fashion
that is one of the answers another one
is that
the traditional notion of time and space
requires a temporal and spatial
continuum
and the temple and spatial continuum
would require that you have basically an
infinite granularity
of things that are happening
which if you turn this into a
constructive language means that you
would have to process infinite amounts
of information in a finite number of
steps
and this leads in contradictions in the
definition of language which means we
cannot properly define these terms
without running into contradictions it's
also not necessary to do this so we can
create constructs that allow us to model
the function of the universe to a very
low level without going to continuity so
i don't think that space time itself
exists but it is an apparent thing that
happens at a certain level of course
graining
there and there are properties uh of
space-time this which means the
regularity and flatness and so on that
are probably required for uh having us
in it so basically for an evolution you
need to have a region of
of the universe where you can apply the
things that you learn in one corner uh
in another corner
and
your control actually works over time
spans and over space
so uh
you there is a reason why the universe
around us looks as if it was happening
in a nearly continuous space and within
nearly continuous time
john
um so i guess um
donald's question
um
i i guess i would want to talk to him
about a fundamental ontology do i think
that time and space are the ultimate
our ultimate reality uh no i i don't
think so i think i heard yoshi saying
something similar to that um
that doesn't by the way mean that i
think they're an illusion and i don't
think yosho was saying that either
i think
we have to be very careful about
when we're talking about these kinds of
levels
because
our
it's not the case and this is going to
go towards my answer the second thing
it's not the case that we can find all
the explanations we want at any
particular level
um
and
there's lots of arguments for this but
um i don't think there's one level from
which all the explanations uh can be
generated
and so in that sense
if what you mean by a theory of
everything is a theory in which all
explanations are reduced to i don't know
quantum mechanic explanations and even
if those are explanations it's
questionable
i i don't see that as a viable project
so
do i think time and space are ultimate
reality no
i don't think that means they're an
illusion
um and i think we should talk about
um
there being something like
a con uh uh a levels uh uh of of reality
um i think that
things not only emerge
out of the quantum base
um they're also constrained
uh by uh you know
law-like features of reality which
aren't properly talked about as being in
time and space
um
so like
i don't know what it would mean to say
like that two plus two equals four is
that temporal spatial that makes no
sense
um even something like equals mc squared
it doesn't make sense to talk about it
being
here or there or starting then or there
um and of course there's lots of other
entities like this so
we have emergence up out of something
like yoshi was talking about a
non-temporal spatial probability realm
and we also have higher order
constraints
um
that
also don't seem to be spatial temporal
and i think
i think of time and space as caught
between that emergence and their
emanation i think part of what we're
doing
when we're playing with quantum
mechanics and relativity relativistic
stuff and trying to reconcile them not
this is not a perfect mapping but we're
trying to get clear about how those
levels uh
are appropriately real together
um
and so
that would be my answer to both
questions i don't think they're
ultimately real i don't think that says
they're an illusion um and i don't think
there is a theory of everything because
i don't think if by theory of everything
you mean i'm gonna pick one level and
that's the level at which i will be able
to explain everything i mean
yoshi for example uh and he's perfectly
legitimate for him doing this is not a
criticism he picks a computational level
right and right and that's the level
from which he works
but that doesn't mean that like
like he thinks uh
he
i don't think he should respond to this
criticism which i take to be a
pseudo-criticism oh but the
computational is ultimately just right
uh thermodynamic or something like that
um
and
you know thermodynamics is a way to talk
about computation it's it's the other
way around
so and in some sense there uh you know
that has a glass panel maybe uh it's a
famous book that he has written in which
he describes uh somewhat metaphorically
a world in which uh people do science
and philosophy by playing a certain game
with glass beats
yes this game is never completely
explained how it works right yeah yeah
so but you you are free to uh project
whatever you want and this so you can
imagine it something like an extremely
complicated abacus
in which you are shifting these glass
speeds around according to very
intricate rules and it allows you to
uh to reason about the world in some
kind of automatic fashion
and you're playing it against each other
but you are playing it according to
rules and the individual that is playing
it is not crucial for this game at all
it's the rules of the game itself
and so i think what happened with
computation is that we discovered a
glass pattern sphere
and we discovered the equivalence of all
glass pattern spiels that can possibly
be constructed
and whenever we found something new to
uh express ideas we also discovered for
this new thing to express ideas that it
can be mapped to a glass bearing sphere
and now there is this big question um
can there be a classified sphere of
everything which means could the
universe exist within a glass pattern
sphere
and uh from where i stand it seems to be
that the answer is yes but i don't know
this uh so i cannot know this before i
haven't succeeded in doing so but in
some sense that's the game that i'm
playing here
it's a good book i love herman hessa i
recommend the book um
um yeah i guess i i tend to uh
i tend to be
a little bit more
pragmatic in the philosophical sense
about uh scientific explanations um and
that they're always bound to
my interests my concerns the concerns of
my group
and again you've said things that are
not inconsistent with that um
so
well i don't know if there's anything
more to say i mean that could launch us
into another long discussion perhaps
but i think i've tried to answer the
question
i don't think they're ultimately real i
think they are intermediate literally
real
right in some ways um as i've tried to
say
um that doesn't mean they're an illusion
uh and i
i i'm suspicious of uh grand reductive
explanations
maybe more suspicious than yeshua uh
because i've watched them fail in the
history
of science and history of philosophy
i think more
and it's unclear whether or not what
yoshi's
proposing does a reduction or does what
i'm not going to talk about what i see
now
um is kind of reciprocal reciprocal
reconstruction between these various
levels of discourse
i see the ai people
changing the minds of the
neuroscientists and vice versa
and the ai people changing the minds of
the psychologists and vice versa it's
not that anyone any one person claims uh
to have this um and i don't know if the
glass speed game would be a claim of
reduction to itself or a game in which
we can really facilitate uh the most
optimal kind of reciprocal
reconstruction between our various
ontologies and strategies of measuring
and explaining the world
so that's how i would answer that sad
face has a question can we get a
discussion on their perspectives of
on the chinese room thought experiment
so should i go first this time because
yeah
please
um
so
the chinese room first of all i don't
think it's an argument i think it's a
demonstration of arguments already that
are already prefigured in descartes
but nevertheless i think searle deserves
credit
um
i think he's right about sort of the
standard system and room reply
uh sorry this the sort of system and
robot replied that's what i meant to say
um
i don't think he has an answer to the
virtual
machine reply um because he didn't
foresee it
but i think he would respond to the
virtual machine reply uh by invoking his
argument about multiple realizability
and that multiple realizability
indicates that an entity an ai
presupposes multiple realizability
ai is not in tr uh any ai is not
intrinsic does not intrinsically exist
it's only attributed because of multiple
realizability i think
the response to that is
i don't think the distinction between
attributed and intrinsic as as clean as
he makes it for example is the
distinction itself intrinsic or
attributed that's a very deep problem
and secondly uh we do think that there
are things that are multiply realizable
that nevertheless intrinsically exist
uh combustion erosion evolution are
clear examples so i don't think his
intuitive criteria of the for splitting
intrinsic and attributed is sufficient i
think we um have to look at other
accounts of how we think things have a
kind of independent existence from us
and so
the degree to which things are
we think things are self-organizing in
some fashion guarantees them a kind of
autonomous existence
that
cyril needs to acknowledge and because
he because he invokes biology and other
things i think he is ultimately
committed uh to what i just said so i
think the chinese room argument doesn't
settle anything in and of itself i think
you get shifted to the virtual machine
reply the virtual machining reply would
get addressed by searle's arguments
about multiple realizability and things
being intrinsic or attributed and i
think that's where the crux of the
argument is and i think
we
don't
always think
that
things
that are multiply realizable are
necessarily attributed and i gave you
some instances and i think that's where
the argument bottoms out and that's
would be my reply to the chinese
argument it seems to me that there are
things that are multiply realizable but
we nevertheless take to be intrinsic uh
that they exist intrinsically not just
by our attribute money
only exists by attribution we all agree
it exists and exists and if we stop
agreeing it doesn't exist
i don't think combustion erosion or
revolution which are multiply realizable
um
exist in that way and so i think his
clean dichotomy breaks down um
and so that would be my my answer um i
think it's important work i i teach this
i teach surah i teach the chinese rule
argument but i teach this whole series
of arguments and it gets down to some
very fundamental issues that cyril
certainly's
argument and his intuitions about how
you distinguish the intrinsic from the
attributed
that's not well argued
that and he does and he doesn't for
example deal with the cases i just
proposed to you of things that are
clearly multiply realizable and
intrinsically exist so his idea that if
it's multiply realizable it must be
attributed
seems to be falsifiable
and i think that there that's where the
argument ends up
yoshi
the multiple realizability is a stent
and for something deeper it has to do
with the fact that causal structure can
be insulated from the substrate
and to insulate causal structure from
the substrate means that you now have a
causal description that happens
independently of the underlying physics
for instance the stock market could work
in different universes the stock market
in some sense is an independent course
attraction as soon as you have touring
machines that can be built in many kinds
of universes you can build causal
structure on top of these touring
machines that is arbitrary right you
could build a computer game in other
universes as long as you can build a
computer in these other universes and
this computer game can have arbitrary
physics like a computer game
can have
and and in the sense i think that money
would also exist if you stop believing
in it as long as we have functional
mechanisms that implement the response
to money so as long as you have banks
implemented in software and atms and
stock markets and amazon is accepting
money and so on and so on
right the money would retain its
functional character independent of the
beliefs of people
and so we have updated in a sense
because we uh no longer just see money
as an agreement between people but uh
this agreement between people has been
extended into machinery that we have
built in the world that works
independently of the beliefs that people
have
and this leads us to the question of
what is software
and software is not a thing
right software is something else in
which sense does software exist
and the best answer that i have so far
discovered is that software is a
physical law
a physical law says if you for instance
arrange matter in this particular way
the following thing will happen
and this is true for software right so
no matter where you are in the universe
in which universe you are if you produce
the following functional arrangement of
things the following thing will happen
this is what software is about so the
programmer in some sense is discovering
by constructing certain very peculiar
circumstances a very specific physical
law
and
i just want to interrupt that's really
cool
that's really cool i really like that
idea so
i want to make sure i'm sorry i want to
make sure i'm following you you're
proposing that software has the same
kind of ontological status as physical
laws exactly yes wow that's really
really cool i hadn't that's cool keep
going please i just wanted to yeah
that's very cool yeah i thought when i
stumbled on this insight that it was a
good insight that basically started
to make sense right because it's an
apparent pattern in the interaction of
many parts
that's very good i like that that's very
good that's very good
so uh this also means uh because i think
that mental states are best understood
as software states
that the ontological status of our
mental states is different from the
ontological states of uh the one that we
attribute to physical things
so this has to do with the notion of
identity of a mental state
that is similar to the identity of a
physical law which means it's not this
point wise identity yeah yeah it's a
functional identity yeah yeah and uh now
let's go back to uh so the original
chinese room argument is very simplistic
in a sense like it's a children's story
myth
that searle himself doesn't believe in
and it's an argument that is by absurd
when he repeats it today made in bad
faith the searle is affiliated with this
his actual contributions to philosophy
have been largely an extension of
austin's speech act theory that are
boring and wouldn't give praise to fame
but the
chinese womb is somebody that everybody
understands because it interfaces with
certain intuitions and it's an intuition
pump
and if you disassemble these intuitions
and try to make them more distinct and
more clear then many of them fall apart
and searle is aware because he's not
stupid he's a very smart individual of
many of the ways in which they fall
apart but he is still repeating the
original chinese room argument because
it's his brand
so
it's not because he believes in it and
if you actually read his uh this work he
is aware of many of the country
arguments and he knows that he needs to
go into a few levels of complications to
have an interesting argument to have an
interesting case that he's making so the
uh superficial level of the chinese room
argument is maybe not that
interesting a slate extension that is
more interesting is the chinese brain
argument that so is also aware of and
the chinese brain argument suggests that
instead of having this library with
books in it in which you execute the
algorithm we use a different
implementation of that whole thing
and instead what we do is we take uh
a mechanization of the neuron itself
so if we accept that what the brain is
doing is facilitated by the interaction
of neurons
their urine has to follow certain rules
in order to make that happen
and maybe we can spell out these rules
in our thought experiment and then we
assign a chinese person to a neuron
and maybe we need a few more we maybe
need 86 billion chinese people in
instead of 1.4 but
it's a thought experiment so not a
problem at all and now instead of
neurons we have chinese which follow
these words or we could use machines
instead of the chinese that are
following these rules
and so uh
i think that this matching between a
neuron and a chinese person is not
completely absurd on the face of it of
course it would be much larger and we
blow it up
and now uh sir would say of course the
chinese brain doesn't have the necessary
and sufficient conditions to uh produce
a conscious mind and then
access to meaning so it doesn't change
anything whether the chinese room or the
chinese brain is performing these
operations the chinese brain is still
not able to
speak chinese because the individual
identities of the chinese people and
their knowledge does not interfere in
any way with their emulation of the
functionality of individual neurons so
now if we have established this case
where sir would say the chinese brain is
not conscious but your brain is
conscious let's see where is the
boundary between those two systems so
let's take your brain blow it up until a
person and the new one have roughly the
same size so change the time so it
doesn't matter how much the chinese need
to talk to each other to make the new
world functionality happening and set
messages back and forth so let's keep
this an identity and now we take
basically take your neurons and uh cell
accepts that neurons are facilitating
mental activity he is not a
mysteriousness or so he doesn't know how
the brain does it but he agrees that the
brain is doing it he's a physicalist in
a sense so now uh
let's replace step by step the neurons
by some other machinery for instance
chinese people or machines that have
neural lag functionality
and so at some point says this loses the
ability to be conscious so the
consciousness is drowning out of the
system
by this replacement process
and what this means is that swirl has a
strong
anti-functionalist position he basically
says that the function of the individual
parts is not producing the essential
behavior they are somehow in essence
he's an essentialist
and i don't know how to get essentialism
to work
because nobody has ever seen an essence
right we can talk about an essence but
it's epi phenomena and the problem with
epi phenomenalism is is the following
epiphany is if you go back to our
dualism from the beginning of
conversation today
it's the idea that there is maybe a read
access from the mind
where the mind is reading physics but no
right access from the mind into physics
so it's not violating the causal closure
of physics
but there is a problem with epi
phenomenalism and that is
uh the phenomenal experience that you
don't think you can explain in the
physical mechanism is not driving
anything of what you are saying
including your utterances of beliefs
so when an epiphany says but i feel and
this cannot be explained by physics this
is caused by physics right because the
epiphenolist has to move their mouths or
move their fingers to
express the statement and all these
movements are caused by an entirely
mechanical process
the true feeling which happens next to
their physical mechanical part of their
mind the philosophical zombie and so on
is not driving any behavior so basically
there would be this locked in
epithelialism that would helplessly
watching their body make statements in
favor or against epiphanicalism but
there would be no causal relationship
between the epithelialism so no
epiphanialist is an epi phenomenalist
because they have phenomenal experience
that cannot be explained by physics that
is the issue here
and so if sir goes down that past he
goes down to a very inconvenient place
that i don't know how to resolve
okay john i know that you have to get
going so how about i read the last
question if it would take too long for
you to reply then send me an email and
then i'll read it when i'm re-editing
this podcast sure okay sure so the last
question comes from xantheus he says or
she says these models of consciousness
seem to focus on explaining the
production of intelligence or
assimilation but it is it isn't
necessarily clear to me why a simulation
should be able to perceive slash
experience itself if we think of meta
consciousness as a combination of
intelligence and consciousness the model
seems to focus mainly on the rise of
intelligence in meta consciousness how
do you explain the ability to perceive
slash experience the simulation
john you start
um
so
it's just a very short easy question
wrap it up for today with this answering
the simple question
uh i mean the the
it's important to ask that question but
it's important to not ask that question
the wrong way
um you can always ask what it is like
and the thing and this is like moore's
thing about the good i can ask that for
any proposal
you can even ask that well you know what
it's like is to have qualia well what's
it like to have qualia do i have qualia
of my quality like you have to you like
there
and this is the difficulty you have to
come to a place where
you're saying that's what it is like to
be what it is like
um and we didn't get into it too much
but like i said at the very beginning
that primary sense of relevance
and i think is a big piece of what it's
likeness it's it's why things stand out
in our salient and are backgrounded it's
why things are aspectualized for us to
use one of soros notions um
and many people are converging on the
idea that the function
of consciousness is this kind of higher
order relevance realization and that's
why it overlaps with working memory and
attentional machinery um so
what it's like
if that's right if what it's like is
this ability
to
do salience landscaping
to have this dynamic texture of how
things are relevant to you
if that's a big part of what it's like
and i think it is by the way because all
of the in the pure consciousness event
all of those other
things that are so beloved all the
adjectival qualias and all the other
things they go away and consciousness
doesn't so those things can't be
necessary conditions for consciousness
if that's par a significant part of what
it's like
then
being intelligent
is also that being intelligent is this
capacity to zero in on relevant
information exclude relevant information
that's why you get
high correlations between measures of
general intelligence and measures of
working memory uh but of course there's
deep inter there's deep
anatomical relations between the
machinery of working memory and
attention and fluid intelligence and
consciousness so
i think the question is now being
to a place where i want to say no no no
and by the way think of notice how you
run on that
you genuinely you gen
you generally attribute
consciousness where you s where you
attribute high orders of intel of of
intelligence
you track them together uh like uh uh
yasha i i i don't well i go further i
don't even eat mammals uh because of
that conclusion about mammals likewise
yeah well there you go um
and so for me right
there there has to be a level at which
you accept an identity statement
because like i said you can always play
the game no matter what i that is what
it if i say x is what it is like you can
then then you can just do ah but what is
it like to write x you have to come to a
place where you accept the i i
an identity claim
and i'm proposing to you that if you
look into the guts of intelligence at
least general intelligence fluid
intelligence
and then you look into the guts of
consciousness and where do we need
consciousness we seem to need
consciousness for situations that are
novel for that are complex that are
ill-defined and situations that don't
have those demands we can we can make
automatic unconscious
uh that's a good point made by burnside
i don't think the questions about
intelligence and consciousness are
ultimately separable questions and i
think there's good reasons for that i've
just given you some and therefore
i think at some level
and i i maybe yosha will like this
when a system is sufficiently
intelligent
it's going to be conscious
uh that's what i would argue
uh for the reasons i've just given and
asking me but what is it like to be
intelligent or what's it like to be like
notice you don't ask the question about
what is it like to be conscious in the
sense of what's behind it
right you have to come to a level at
which you say
no that's what that's this this is what
it is liking is this is the function
it's performing this is the kind of
process it is
if not if you don't put some bound on
where that identity is possible then you
just get an infinite regret aggressive
this question because no matter what i
pause it for you you can step back and
say but what is it like to x
and then i'll say well what's it like to
x is to y and you'll say but what is it
like to why this is like the
the four-year-old asks you why all the
time right you have to come to a place
and what i can't give you is i can't
give you a phenomenological experience
of that
because you're trying to ask how
phenomenological experience is itself
possible
what i can give you are these plausible
arguments about overlapping
functionality
etc that's how i would answer that
question
okay let me try
so uh there is an issue for instance
with free will free will is
an intermediate representation i think
free will is what decision making under
uncertainty looks like from your own
perspective between discovering the
first person perspective and
deconstructing it again
and once you have destruct deconstructed
your first person perspective you
basically realize that there is a
particular procedure that you are
following when you are making your
decisions
and when you observe yourself following
that procedure you will not have an
experience of free will
it's just we rarely get to the point in
our short lives where we fully
deconstruct this
and i just give this example to argue
for the possibility and i'm not sure
there's no certainty there that
consciousness might be an intermediate
representation
it's best the simplification of the
state of affairs and which we are in
before we automate all the necessary
behaviors that an intelligent system
might have want to exhibit in uh when
it's being confronted with the world in
which we are in
the reason why we
experience things is not because
physical systems would be capable of
doing so it's quite the opposite neurons
cannot experience what it would be like
to be a person that is confronted with a
complex world and it changes its
attitudes in response to what's
happening to it in this complex world
but for the organization of the neurons
that is uh controlling the behavior of
the organism
it would be very useful
to have this
knowledge of what it would be like to be
a person that is changing its attitudes
in response to what's happening to it
so what the neurons are doing is they
implement a model of what that would be
like a simulation of what that would be
like in the same way as the neurons
create a simulation of euclidean
universe with objects that bump into
each other and have causal interaction
the neurons create the model of agents
that try a care about future states and
how they play out and make decisions
about this and one of these agents is
going to be a model of the organism
itself and the behavior that motivates
the organism
and the reason why we experience things
is not because we are in the brain it's
because we are in that model we are in
that simulation we are in that dream
that is woven by the brain to explain
its own behavior the experience sings
for the same reason that the character
in a novel experiences things it's
because it's written in the story
and the story that we experience of
course is not a linear narrative made up
of words
it's a more complicated world it's a
causal structure
that contains
the necessary properties to simulate
physics and personality and agency and
so on
and we find ourselves in that dream
so our experience of the world is
virtual
it's a result of the capacity of neurons
to dream and to create dreams
there was a question that came from anil
seth professor anil seth and there's a
podcast of anil seth on this channel if
you'd like to check it out on
consciousness professor anil seth asks
yosha do you believe consciousness to be
substrate independent i.e a silicone
computer in principle could be conscious
and if so why yosha responded to me via
email and said there is no known reason
why the process playing out in the brain
cannot be functionally replicated on a
silicon-based computer i think that
consciousness is not so much a side
effect of how a biological brain makes
sense of the world but of the need to
create a coherent representation out of
dynamic perceptual features because of
this i think it's likely that
intelligent autonomous sense making
agents with similar complexity as ours
may be considered conscious in ways that
are comparable to ours even if they run
on a silicon substrate
there's an important caveat our
computers provide some functionality
which is hard to achieve in the brain
they're almost fully deterministic
they're synchronized in ways that allow
each part to rely on the functionality
of all others at any given time and they
can make information available very
quickly throughout the entire processing
architecture crucial parts of the
phenomenology of human consciousness
especially reflexive consciousness may
be the result of self-organizing
processes that our brains cannot do
without but that may not be necessary in
our digital computers
thank you both for coming the audience
thanks you there were i think 500 people
at its peak and right now it's around
430 or so so it hovered from 400 to 500.
thank you all thank you yoshi thank you
john
thank you kurt thank you for setting
this up it was a very pleasant
conversation i was surprised that we
don't seem to have that many
disagreements
well maybe maybe it's the level we were
talking at i i sort of wanted to talk at
a very fundamental ontological level and
um
i wanted to understand you much more
than just sort of simply debate you uh
likewise and i think that we have a uh
both bound by the same rules of the
glass pattern field in a way yes yes yes
yeah very good so
thank you very much it's a great
pleasure meeting you uh
enjoyed this conversation uh amanda
thank you soon thank you very much
take care of both of you
and yoshi you'll send me your audio
great okay we'll communicate over email
all right have a good afternoon everyone
thank you a good rest of the day
wherever you are
thank you everyone thank you for your
time and attention
okay everyone i will be sticking around
and i'll answer some audience questions
but i gotta get
going for about one minute
okay so phrase 14 phrasal 14 wants to
know what i consider thomas metzinger on
the program i don't know who that is
so i will look into that i'll make a
note
yes i should let you know that there's a
sponsor of today's episode and it's a
new one it's a small podcast by the name
of the anagi podcast i'll type it here
and it's run by someone named thiago who
reached out to me and he touches on
similar themes so if you look at so that
person is who's responsible for bringing
this talk together
thank you
thiago okay
i guess i should get going if there are
any quick questions for me
then i'll answer right now if not then i
will say goodbye to you all and get
something to eat
okay so is there any chance of having
nema arkani hamed on the channel i've
reached out to nema several times it
turns out that my brother
went to university with them studying
physics at the same time so i'll see if
i can use that connection though they
parted ways after graduate school
lisa feldman barrett yes she's on the
list though i need to look into her work
et vin wants to know if i expect it to
have more disagreements i thought i was
surprised at what yosha said where he
said well we agree more than we disagree
i thought it was mainly filled with
disagreements or more about
clarifications than disagreements which
can be their own disagreement giulio
wants to know what i get a traditional
advice monk the answer is yes and if you
take a look at this video that i have
about the 2022 plans
you'll see that i do
have a great interest in speaking with
people from the more eastern ends of the
philosophical spectrum
so yes the answer is yes and that'll be
toward the latter half of the year
now the reason for why it's so far away
is because it
my background is in math and physics so
let's say i'm supposed to let's say i'm
going to be interviewing someone for
their theory of everything like let's
say garrett lisey it'll be much easier
for me to understand his theory than it
would be for me to understand someone
who's an advice a monk
it would take much more time because i'd
like to implement some meditative
strategies that is i'd like to meditate
some meditation practice
in order to experientially understand
what they're saying and it's not
it's not trivial to me and i don't take
it
lightly martin you want to know is bach
a materialist dualist or idealist he
says he's not an idealist he comes close
which isn't he's like a physicalist
idealist and he's not i don't know if
he's a materialist i think he would it
would be closer to materialism one of my
goals with this theo locution was going
to be that
and luckily i didn't have to interject
much i thought that what was going to
happen was they were going to be
difficult to follow because much of what
they say
and this is evidenced in the comment
section of any of their videos
people can't follow people have a
difficult time understanding because
it's so steeped in cognitive scientific
jargon
terminology that's unfamiliar to most
and then
on top of that with yoshibok there's
computer science analogies and then on
top of that there's yoshibox idiolect
like his personal language where the
analogies
between computer science and reality
are made in a manner that is unique to
him and he's so
familiar with his own model that i don't
think
him nor
nor john verveiki are aware when they're
speaking above or below someone
and i was thinking that i would have to
step in and slow down and break down
sentences
however that didn't need to happen
at all
okay well
thank you everyone thank you and have a
great rest of your day
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jymungal it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you